Eat my greens, nutrition You ain't on my vibe, then I don't gotta listen Working out, sleeping in, taking vitamins Vitamin A, vitamin B, vitamin C Vitamin D, vitamin bitch, vitamin please Hi, it's Joel Blackstock and you're listening to the Tab Root Therapy Podcast I'm here today with Corey Rasmussen and Jared Hardy of the Hardy Nutritional Company And I've seen their products do some pretty amazing things
吃我的蔬菜，补充营养。如果你和我不合拍，那我就不必听。锻炼、睡觉、服用维生素。维生素A、维生素B、维生素C。维生素D，维生素混蛋，维生素拜托。嗨，我是Joel Blackstock，你正在收听的是Tab Root Therapy播客。今天我和Hardy营养公司的Corey Rasmussen和Jared Hardy在一起。我见过他们的产品产生了一些非常神奇的效果。
with different people. These aren't people who approached me and told me that, you know, they had a product and they wanted to partner or something. And they're also not anybody who's advertising I'd ever encountered. What happened was, you know, we're a treatment resistant clinic and complex PTSD clinic. And we work with people that have been in a lot of different kinds of therapy. A lot of times dopamine disorders, especially, um, you can deal with the trauma that is fueling the genetic expression of, you know, the gene causing the dopamine disorder, but you're always going to have a little bit of a dopamine disorder, you know, schizophrenia or, um, bipolar disorder or, um, OCD are, you know, hard to treat without medication,
在不同的人身上。这些人并不是主动找到我，告诉我他们有什么产品想要合作之类的。他们也不是我遇到过的任何做广告的人。情况是这样的，我们是一家治疗抵抗型诊所和复杂PTSD诊所。我们与许多接受过各种不同治疗的人合作。很多时候，尤其是多巴胺紊乱，嗯，你可以处理导致多巴胺紊乱基因表达的创伤，但你总会有一点多巴胺紊乱，你知道，精神分裂症，或者，嗯，双相情感障碍，或者，嗯，强迫症，你知道，没有药物很难治疗，
but also if you've got a very treatment-resistant form of a condition, a lot of times you've got to play with the medication all the time. You know, stress can make it not work as well. And trauma therapy helps, but we heard from multiple patients independently that they had tried all these different things and they were having good luck with Hardy. And so I was interested and I looked it up. And, you know, unlike a lot of the fad stuff that is kind of pseudoscientific out there, because a lot of people, you know, have a critique of psychopharmacology and a lot of the systems that we use in this country that aren't great. But they use it to push a product that is also a scam. You know, you can have a very good takedown of the system,
但如果你患有一种非常难治的疾病，很多时候你必须一直调整药物。你知道，压力会让药物效果变差。创伤治疗有帮助，但我们从多位患者那里独立了解到，他们尝试了所有这些不同的方法，而在Hardy的产品上取得了不错的效果。所以我很感兴趣，就去查了一下。而且，你知道，不像市面上很多伪科学的跟风产品，因为很多人，你知道，对精神药理学以及我们这个国家使用的许多系统有批评，这些系统并不好。但他们利用这一点来推销一种同样是骗局的产品。你知道，你可以对这个系统进行很好的抨击，
or you can have a very good critique, and then still be pushing something that is fraudulent or unhelpful. And the hearty stuff, you know, there was no like, oh, our secret ingredient that works for everybody is, you know, hornet venom from China or, you know, on the mountainside of Tibet, there's a rare blue flower that will cure, you know, there wasn't any of that kind of, um, marketing. It was just that they were talking about bioavailability and how, you know, um, chelation, they have one of the most advanced
或者你可以进行很好的批评，但仍然在推销一些欺诈性或无用的东西。而Hardy的产品，你知道，没有什么“哦，我们对每个人都有效的秘方是，你知道，来自中国的黄蜂毒液，或者，你知道，在西藏的山坡上，有一种稀有的蓝花可以治愈”，你知道，没有那种营销。他们只是在谈论生物利用度，以及如何，你知道，嗯，螯合作用，他们拥有世界上最先进的
chelation processes in the world, which is how you make the vitamin, um, be available to the body. If the, if it holds on too tight, tight, then you pass it and you don't get it in your system. And if it doesn't hold it at all, then it will break down in the container. So a lot of things that are labeled to contain a vitamin that you take doesn't really mean that you absorb that vitamin. And they use micronutrition, you know, with different time release things. There's a lot of science in it, but they weren't reinventing the wheel. They were just saying that we are actually taking lots of steps. Our product is expensive, and it's because it's built to make these things available to the body when and where they need them during this digestive process.
螯合工艺之一，这就是你如何让维生素，嗯，被人体吸收的方法。如果它抓得太紧，太紧，那么你就会把它排泄掉，而无法进入你的系统。如果它根本抓不住，那么它在容器里就会分解。所以很多标有含有某种维生素的产品，你吃了并不意味着你真的吸收了那种维生素。他们使用微量营养，你知道，带有不同的缓释功能。其中有很多科学依据，但他们并没有重新发明轮子。他们只是说我们确实采取了很多步骤。我们的产品很贵，这是因为它旨在在消化过程中需要的时间和地点让这些物质被人体吸收。
And because it wasn't some secret ingredient, kind of going back to the drawing board and saying I was interested in it and looked more at the science of it. So I wanted to have those guys on today to talk about their product. You can order it from their website. You know, one day I would like, you know, our clinic is started with just me and now we have some other therapists that do other things. And we now have the QEG brain mapping and neurostimulation. But the goal was to collect all of this brain-based medicine, you know, a myofascial release practitioner, someone who could do gut health and nutrition, and have all these people together so that we could start to build the future protocols that we're going to need to treat trauma
而且因为它不是什么秘方，回到原点，我说我对它很感兴趣，并更多地研究了它的科学性。所以我今天想请这些人来谈谈他们的产品。你可以从他们的网站上订购。你知道，有一天我希望，你知道，我们的诊所刚开始只有我一个人，现在我们有其他治疗师做其他事情。我们现在有了QEG脑图和神经刺激。但目标是收集所有这些基于大脑的医学，你知道，肌筋膜释放从业者，能做肠道健康和营养的人，把这些人聚在一起，这样我们就可以开始建立治疗创伤所需的未来方案，
and change the kind of things that we want to change. And so being able to collaborate with them is helpful. And having, you know, the QEG brain mapping, being able to learn what's working where, and what order do you need certain kinds of treatment. I mean, that's all part of the stuff and part of the reason why we want to do all of this stuff in the same building and collaborate with each other instead of just referring to providers that talk once or twice. And I hope one day Hardy will be part of that, that we can, you know, have a supplement program or something. We don't now. So I don't have any business affiliation with them. They did send me some free samples in the mail after the podcast. So I appreciate that. You know, full disclosure, I got some free things. But, you know, I use their stuff. I think it's very helpful. And I wanted to make it available to more people just because I'd heard success stories from patients. So I'll go ahead and roll that interview. And I appreciate you listening. effects, plural, really, of what you're doing. From our experience, it really is an important addition.
并改变我们想要改变的那种事情。所以能够与他们合作是有帮助的。而且拥有，你知道，QEG脑图，能够了解什么在什么地方起作用，以及你需要什么顺序的某种治疗。我的意思是，这都是其中的一部分，也是为什么我们想在同一栋楼里做所有这些事情并互相合作，而不是仅仅转介给只谈话一两次的提供者。我希望有一天Hardy能成为其中的一部分，我们可以，你知道，有一个补充剂计划之类的。我们现在没有。所以我与他们没有任何商业往来。他们在播客之后确实给我寄了一些免费样品。所以我很感激。你知道，完全披露，我得到了一些免费的东西。但是，你知道，我使用他们的产品。我认为它非常有帮助。我只是因为听到了患者的成功故事，所以想让更多人能用到它。所以我现在就开始播放那段采访。感谢你们的收听。效果，复数，确实，你们正在做的事情。根据我们的经验，这确实是一个重要的补充。
We're doing a nutrient synergy. We're trying to be as complete as we can and to optimize that. And it works well for the majority of people. Many people also benefit from individualized treatment. In addition, things like N-acetylcysteine added to what we're doing. It's been shown to break down biofilms of organisms in the gut, and that can be very useful, make antibiotics more effective, make antimicrobials more effective, antifungals, for example. And we see a lot of people with gut health issues. So we work with a lot of
我们正在做一种营养协同作用。我们试图尽可能全面并优化它。它对大多数人效果很好。许多人也从个性化治疗中受益。此外，像N-乙酰半胱氨酸添加到我们正在做的事情中。它已被证明可以分解肠道中生物体的生物膜，这可能非常有用，使抗生素更有效，使抗菌剂更有效，例如抗真菌剂。我们看到很多人有肠道健康问题。所以我们与很多
different practitioners specialized in gut health, specialized in psychiatry, of course. We need medical doctors to help people come off medications because that's essential. When we add the nutrients, they need to come off the medications. Eventually the optimal dose of medication is zero in the majority of cases. That's true of thyroid hormone as well. You're talking about medical things where you can get the body to make what it needs, like, you know, and it's also seen as a precursor for glutathione. That's right. And so, you know, having a universal antioxidant at the peak capacity that your liver can hold
不同的肠道健康从业者合作，当然还有专门从事精神病学的从业者。我们需要医生来帮助人们停药，因为这至关重要。当我们添加营养素时，他们需要停药。最终，在大多数情况下，药物的最佳剂量是零。甲状腺激素也是如此。你谈论的是医学上的事情，你可以让身体制造它所需要的东西，比如，你知道，它也被视为谷胱甘肽的前体。没错。所以，你知道，拥有一个处于肝脏所能容纳的峰值容量的通用抗氧化剂
is useful because, you know, if you're at least in America, you're probably going to encounter a poison somewhere, you know, so going ahead and you can't take glutathione orally, you just pass it. You can inject it, which is kind of arduous and expensive. But if you take the ingredients your body needs to make it, then you're always running at the highest level of having that. And when you encounter high cholesterol or you get the triple baconator or whatever, you breathe in fumes in the city or something, you're just better prepared to be able to handle that without liver inflammation and a lot of other things. I think it helps with neuroplasticity too.
是有用的，因为，你知道，如果你至少在美国，你很可能会在某个地方遇到毒素，你知道，所以继续前进，你不能口服谷胱甘肽，你只会把它排泄掉。你可以注射它，这有点艰苦且昂贵。但如果你摄入身体制造它所需的成分，那么你总是处于拥有最高水平的状态。当你遇到高胆固醇或吃了三重培根汉堡之类的东西，你在城市里吸入烟雾或什么东西，你只是准备得更好，能够处理它而不会导致肝脏炎症和许多其他事情。我认为它对神经可塑性也有帮助。
Exactly. So our focus is on providing the body with all of the raw materials that it can't make on its own. We need those essential nutrients in optimal amounts. And in some cases, it varies from person to person by genetics. So we provide a foundation which works for most people for many different mental health conditions. We have extensive research right now with ADHD in adults and children showing that nutrients are very effective for attention to restore optimal attention for people but in addition to that the studies have looked at the clinical global impression in these trials for children and adults and it's very effective for mood and anxiety components of the adhd and that matches our experience in the other publications that have happened, dozens of publications, in fact, not all of them blinded. We're just getting into the realm where researchers are starting to do blinded trials. Would that be the same thing as like a randomized controlled trial we do here?
没错。所以我们的重点是为身体提供它无法自行制造的所有原材料。我们需要这些必需营养素的最佳量。在某些情况下，它因人的遗传而异。所以我们提供了一个对大多数人来说对许多不同心理健康状况都有效的基石。我们目前有关于成人和儿童ADHD的广泛研究，表明营养素对注意力非常有效，可以恢复人们的最佳注意力，但除此之外，这些研究还观察了儿童和成人的临床总体印象，它对ADHD的情绪和焦虑成分非常有效，这与我们在其他出版物中的经验相符，事实上，有几十篇出版物，并非所有出版物都是盲法的。我们刚刚进入研究人员开始进行盲法试验的领域。那会和我们这里做的随机对照试验是一回事吗？
Is that what you mean by blinded? Yes, a randomized controlled trial. So they randomize individuals to different groups some receive our daily essential nutrients treatment and others receive a placebo do you make blends for specific conditions yeah have you ever thought of that i mean the daily the daily, you make like a, you know, kind of a general micronutrient vitamin. Do you make specific things for different issues? In a way, it turns out that we do. We don't have specific, well, we have additional products that we add as needed. And so we're creating our own blend by adding more relevant products so inositol for example is very useful to take the edge off anxiety do you combine that with choline with choline yes choline is excellent for racing thoughts and so it's individual reduction and obsession yes obsessions racing thoughts
这就是你所说的盲法吗？是的，随机对照试验。所以他们将个体随机分配到不同的组，一些人接受我们的日常必需营养素治疗，另一些人接受安慰剂。你们为特定疾病制作混合物吗？是的，你想过吗？我的意思是，日常的，日常的，你们制作一种，你知道，某种通用的微量营养素维生素。你们为不同的问题制作特定的东西吗？在某种程度上，事实证明我们确实做了。我们没有特定的，嗯，我们有根据需要添加的额外产品。所以我们通过添加更相关的产品来创建我们自己的混合物，例如肌醇对缓解焦虑非常有用。你把它和胆碱结合吗？和胆碱，是的，胆碱对赛车般的思维非常出色，所以它是对强迫症和痴迷的个体减少，是的，强迫症，赛车般的思维。
yeah the the inositol is excellent for physical symptoms of anxiety and there's good research for it on its own in psychiatry but in synergy with other nutrients it seems that we don't need as much. Do you do anything with L-theanine? L-theanine? Yeah. Yes, in some cases that is very useful as an add-on. I was just curious. I mean, not that you should. Those are sums that we have seen a lot of good effect with treatment-resistant mood disorders.
是的，肌醇对焦虑的身体症状非常出色，并且在精神病学中它本身就有很好的研究，但在与其他营养素的协同作用下，似乎我们不需要那么多。你做过关于L-茶氨酸的事情吗？L-茶氨酸？是的。是的，在某些情况下，作为附加物非常有用。我只是好奇。我的意思是，并不是说你应该这样做。这些是我们看到在治疗抵抗型情绪障碍方面有很好效果的总和。
Yes. Yeah, it can be very useful. And that is part of our clinical reference for health practitioners. We've compiled from experience with clinicians and patients over the years what seems to be most effective in different situations. And with anxiety, L-theanine, it can be very useful. So we have a protocol there to add. It can be different for different people. It needs to be optimized for dosage for different people, of course.
是的。是的，它可能非常有用。这是我们为健康从业者提供的临床参考的一部分。多年来，我们根据临床医生和患者的经验汇编了在不同情况下似乎最有效的内容。对于焦虑，L-茶氨酸，它可能非常有用。所以我们有一个添加的方案。对不同的人来说可能不同。当然，它需要针对不同的人优化剂量。
But we start with the base of the essential nutrients, and we add from there. So depending on the individual situation, some of those add-ons can be very useful and important. Could you speak briefly about some of the newer advancements? I mean, newer as in 20 years and some of these, but some of the newer information that we have about, one, bioavailability, two, taking precursors to get something that you want instead of just eating the thing that you want and then three um synergistic
但我们从必需营养素的基础开始，然后从那里添加。因此，根据个人的情况，其中一些附加物可能非常有用和重要。你能简要谈谈一些较新的进展吗？我的意思是，较新是指20年，其中一些是这样，但我们拥有的一些关于，第一，生物利用度，第二，服用前体来获得你想要的东西，而不是仅仅吃你想要的东西，然后第三，嗯，协同作用
the two things by themselves have an effect or no effect but combining them gives you none of the individual effects and a completely new one because there's a combination you know a lot of this stuff needs to be thought more of like baking soda and vinegar. You know, it's not that, you know, if you drink baking soda and vinegar, you have a total, if you eat a handful of baking soda and taste what that's like, and then you drink vinegar and you taste what that's like, that's nothing like mixing them together and drinking the thing that's just the water and salt left behind. I mean, there's a reaction. And, you know, obviously your liver metabolism and gut health is a little bit different than that. But, you know, a lot of the things that are not quite yet commercialized or not all the research is even available yet is saying, you know, if you seed the gut with the right thing, you know, because the gut is one of the only other places, the only other place other than our brain that has neurons. I mean, we have an enteric nervous system, which not a lot of people know.
这两样东西本身有效果或没有效果，但结合起来给你带来任何单独的效果，而是一个全新的效果，因为有一个组合，你知道，很多这种东西需要更多地被认为是小苏打和醋。你知道，并不是说，你知道，如果你喝小苏打和醋，你有一个总的，如果你吃一把小苏打并尝尝那是什么味道，然后你喝醋并尝尝那是什么味道，那和把它们混合在一起喝下剩下的水和盐完全不同。我的意思是，有一个反应。而且，你知道，显然你的肝脏代谢和肠道健康与此略有不同。但是，你知道，很多尚未商业化或甚至还没有所有研究的东西都在说，你知道，如果你用正确的东西播种肠道，你知道，因为肠道是除了我们大脑之外唯一拥有神经元的其他地方之一。我的意思是，我们有一个肠神经系统，很多人不知道。
So there's, and it's talking directly, you know, to the body brain. They say your gut is your second brain. And we know from experience that you have to have a healthy gut in order for the nutrients to uptake appropriately. As a matter of fact, if your gut is unhealthy, if you don't have the proper microbiome there, you can feed that nutrients and actually create more of a problem. It just feeds off of that stuff. So it's different than a medication. a medication gets into your bloodstream pretty quick we're talking about an ecosystem which i think is harder for people to understand
所以有，而且它正在直接，你知道，与身体大脑对话。他们说你的肠道是你的第二个大脑。我们从经验中知道，你必须有一个健康的肠道，营养素才能适当地吸收。事实上，如果你的肠道不健康，如果你那里没有适当的微生物群，你可能会喂养那些营养素，实际上会造成更多的问题。它只是以那些东西为食。所以它不同于药物。药物很快进入你的血液，我们谈论的是一个生态系统，我认为这比药丸更难让人理解。
yeah than a pill yeah and harder to microbiome is a synergy effect the more complicated your treatment the more pushback you're going to get from research, you know, because you can't turn it into a number. You know, if I eat Welbutrin, I know exactly what that does to a neurotransmitter in 90% of people. If I'm saying, okay, what if the gut, this bacteria goes into the gut and then it takes root and then we rule out the people where it didn't actually respond to that. And then you feed that bacteria, this combination of thing, and then that produces a desirable byproduct i mean that's a lot bigger and harder of a study man i got to get my phd yes so as long as we can fit everything into one capsule we can do a study and it's not much different than studying food because food contains many factors and it's kind's the synergy of those factors that keep us healthy.
是的，比药丸更难。而且更难，微生物群是一种协同效应。你的治疗越复杂，你从研究中得到的阻力就越大，你知道，因为你不能把它变成一个数字。你知道，如果我吃安非他酮，我知道这在90%的人中对神经递质有什么影响。如果我说，好吧，如果肠道，这种细菌进入肠道，然后它扎根，然后我们排除那些实际上没有反应的人。然后你喂养那种细菌，这种东西的组合，然后产生一种理想的副产品，我的意思是，那是一个更大、更难的研究，伙计，我得拿到我的博士学位。是的，所以只要我们能把所有东西装进一个胶囊里，我们就可以做一个研究，这和研究食物没什么不同，因为食物包含许多因素，正是这些因素的协同作用让我们保持健康。
You know, if we're eating well, you know, so it's, it's really not a stretch, but the reality on the ground is research grants, for example, for so many years, for, for decades and say the last century, for example, for so many years, for decades, and say the last century, you know, there's been an explosion of science, but it's been one factor at a time. It's been researched. Which doesn't measure through two or three things working together. I mean, that's why to get these protocols, the biggest breakthroughs in mental health have not been when somebody came out with a new antipsychotic, because antipsychotics are very expensive to research. And so it's like these pharmaceutical companies, I'm trying to give general listeners a little bit of industry information about the assumptions you guys are acting on, you know, so that they understand this.
你知道，如果我们吃得好，你知道，所以，这真的不是牵强附会，但现实情况是研究经费，例如，这么多年来，几十年来，比如说上个世纪，例如，这么多年来，几十年来，比如说上个世纪，你知道，科学有了爆炸式增长，但它是一个因素一个因素地研究的。它没有测量两三个东西一起工作的情况。我的意思是，这就是为什么为了获得这些方案，心理健康方面最大的突破并不是当有人推出一种新的抗精神病药时，因为抗精神病药的研究非常昂贵。所以这就像这些制药公司，我试图给普通听众提供一点关于你们所依据的假设的行业信息，你知道，这样他们就能理解这一点。
But like it's very easy to create a new statin, which is a cholesterol medication. That's why we have like 20 that we don't need because they're all about the same. You just play with a sugar molecule until you get it to be slightly different. I bonded this here and now I can patent it. It's a new thing. And so you, you fudge some research that says, Hey, this one's slightly better for your liver than all the other statins because statins are not great for your liver. And then, um, you, you know, two or three years into it, they do some more trials and realize that actually it's about the same as a torvastatin and all the ones that we already had. But by then it's generic anyways, you don't care.
但就像创造一种新的他汀类药物非常容易，这是一种胆固醇药物。这就是为什么我们有大约20种我们不需要的药物，因为它们都差不多。你只是玩弄一个糖分子，直到你让它略有不同。我在这里结合了这个，现在我可以申请专利了。这是一个新东西。所以你，你捏造了一些研究，说，嘿，这个对你的肝脏比所有其他他汀类药物稍微好一点，因为他汀类药物对你的肝脏不太好。然后，嗯，你，你知道，两三年后，他们做了更多的试验，意识到实际上它和阿托伐他汀以及我们已经拥有的所有药物差不多。但到那时它已经是仿制药了，反正你也不在乎。
And you get to advertise that to every like old guy that's sitting in front of the TV, you know, screaming at the news and like eating fried chicken. So like you make a bunch of money making a drug that we don't need. What we really need is antibiotics and antipsychotics because we have germ resistant bacteria and we have mental health conditions that are very hard to treat. You know, the majority of the people that I see for bipolar disorder that is treatment resistant and extremely genetic, you know, like it's been on, they've been on all of these different combinations of meds forever. The symptoms are never going to quite go away. We got rid of the trauma that was underneath the genetic expression, but the genetic expression,
而且你可以向坐在电视机前，你知道，对着新闻尖叫并吃炸鸡的每个老家伙做广告。所以就像你赚了一大笔钱制造了一种我们不需要的药物。我们真正需要的是抗生素和抗精神病药，因为我们有耐药细菌，我们有非常难治疗的心理健康状况。你知道，我看到的绝大多数双相情感障碍患者都是治疗抵抗型且极具遗传性的，你知道，就像它一直存在一样，他们永远都在服用所有这些不同的药物组合。症状永远不会完全消失。我们摆脱了遗传表达之下的创伤，但遗传表达，
even without the trauma is still very high. And that's where Hardy comes in and has been very helpful. Um, and so there's a huge resistance to researching these things. And when you're, you're, it's been pretty recent that they've started to research how things work together. And the biggest breakthrough in antipsychotics, which is come back to where I started is not that they came out with a new pill. I wish they did that. They need to do that. I'm not saying it's a bad thing to do. If you ever get one, it's going to be where there's some kind of socialized sector of research like in Switzerland. But the biggest breakthroughs have been when they discovered that when you take a mood stabilizer, an antisuppressant, an antidepressant, and an antipsychotic, and you combine them, that there is a synergistic effect
即使没有创伤，仍然非常高。这就是Hardy发挥作用的地方，并且非常有帮助。嗯，所以研究这些东西有巨大的阻力。而且当你，你，最近才开始研究事物是如何协同工作的。抗精神病药最大的突破，回到我开始的地方，并不是他们推出了一种新药丸。我希望他们这样做。他们需要这样做。我并不是说这是一件坏事。如果你能得到一个，那将是在瑞士那样的社会化研究部门。但最大的突破是当他们发现当你服用情绪稳定剂、抗抑郁药和抗精神病药，并将它们结合起来时，有一种协同效应
where they behave totally differently and it's able to stabilize a condition sometimes because you have a paradoxical reaction where you can't get any more anxious so then it pushes you back to your baseline sometimes where there's a combination in the brain that we don't really understand but it's been combinations of medication that have become the bigger breakthroughs in mental health not a new discovery we need new discoveries and we should fund those um and there's like a lot of corruption issues there that drive me nuts. But that this combining these things is very hard to study, which is why it took mainstream medicine so long to do it. And you guys are kind of on the frontier of doing this in a new way. I think research is not going to validate for a while because there's nothing in it for them, not because it isn't evidence-based. Yes, it's certainly not nearly the lucrative opportunity that patentable medications are. That's for sure. But we have researchers independent of our company who have done these blinded trials. And they do it because they care about solving the issues, the real issues at hand.
它们表现得完全不同，并且能够稳定一种状况，有时是因为你有一种矛盾的反应，你不能再焦虑了，所以它把你推回基线，有时大脑中有一种我们并不真正理解的组合，但正是药物的组合成为了心理健康方面更大的突破，而不是新的发现。我们需要新的发现，我们应该资助这些，嗯，那里有很多腐败问题让我发疯。但结合这些东西非常难研究，这就是为什么主流医学花了这么长时间才做到这一点。而你们在以一种新的方式做这件事，处于前沿。我认为研究在一段时间内不会验证它，因为这对他们没有任何好处，而不是因为它不是基于证据的。是的，这当然远不是专利药物那样有利可图的机会。那是肯定的。但我们有独立于我们公司的研究人员进行了这些盲法试验。他们这样做是因为他们关心解决手头的问题，真正的问题。
And it's not the quick get rich way. Let's leave the clinical psychology students, because it's never a clinical psychologist. It's always a clinical psychology student that just took their one-on-one class and has decided, I don't know what research is, you know, 10 years into my thing. It's like, I've run randomized controlled trials to do it i'm not bad at reading research i just know if i can replicate something in the room over and over again then that's the thing to follow but it's like they'll send you an email being like well this isn't 15 years old yet i don't know if you knew that like correct yeah well we've you, we've been doing the nutrient treatments and we call them treatments because they, they replace for ADHD. I mean, I definitely think you can get there with
而且这不是快速致富的方法。让我们离开临床心理学学生，因为从来都不是临床心理学家。总是临床心理学学生，他们刚刚上了他们的一对一课程，并决定，我不知道什么是研究，你知道，在我做这件事10年之后。就像，我已经进行了随机对照试验来做这件事，我不擅长阅读研究，我只是知道如果我能在房间里一遍又一遍地复制某件事，那么这就是要遵循的事情，但就像他们会给你发一封电子邮件说，嗯，这还没有15年，我不知道你是否知道，像正确，是的，好吧，我们已经，我们一直在做营养治疗，我们称它们为治疗，因为它们，它们替代了ADHD。我的意思是，我绝对认为你可以通过
nutrition where I'm really careful to talk about going off medication, even though I'm not a pill pusher, but I also am not totally anti-psychiatry. Schizophrenia and dopamine disorders, schizophrenia, obsessive compulsive, and bipolar disorder, you can lower your baseline some of the time, you know, but the odds that you're never going to need to be on that medication ever again, I think research really, you know, a lot of people get really angry with me because I can't tell them I can, oh, you can look at light and color and I'll do the pointer and we'll do somatic experiencing. You'll just never have schizophrenia again. That's just not how it works. And the psychotic break is so damaging to your, to your brain and to your, you know, practical reality that I just want to make clear that when you're talking about that, you're talking about, you know, addictive medication or medication that could be better treated with therapy and health.
营养达到那个目标，虽然我非常小心地谈论停药，即使我不是一个推销药丸的人，但我也不完全反精神病学。精神分裂症和多巴胺紊乱，精神分裂症，强迫症和双相情感障碍，你可以降低你的基线，你知道，但你永远不需要再服用那种药物的几率，我认为研究真的，你知道，很多人对我非常生气，因为我不能告诉他们我可以，哦，你可以看光和颜色，我会做指针，我们会做躯体体验。你将永远不会再有精神分裂症了。事情不是那样运作的。精神病发作对你的大脑和你的，你知道，实际现实是如此具有破坏性，我只是想明确一点，当你谈论这个时，你谈论的是，你知道，成瘾性药物或可以通过治疗和健康更好地治疗的药物。
You know, it's not in every condition. You know, you're not saying that you can, you know, 100% cure cancer, that you can remove that. Because then, you know, it's a mental health podcast. A lot of people say that. So I just want to qualify what you're saying. Right. Yes. Thank you.
你知道，并不是在每种情况下。你知道，你并不是说你可以，你知道，100%治愈癌症，你可以消除它。因为那样，你知道，这是一个心理健康播客。很多人这么说。所以我只是想限定你所说的。对。是的。谢谢。
It's psychiatric medications we're talking about and we can only remove the psychiatric medications insofar as the nutrients are effective in replacing the action of those medications yeah so you know it's not the same in every case but in the majority of cases, certainly we've seen with bipolar disorder, it looks very much like a treatment. Psychiatrists use it that way. At least we can choose different words and say that people can manage the rest of their life without symptoms by using nutrients alone. That's what we see and it's people can replace uh mood stabilizer medications with mood stabilizing nutrients which are what nature intended for mood stabilization uh you know to to regulate anxiety well and with
我们谈论的是精神科药物，我们只能在营养素有效替代这些药物作用的范围内移除精神科药物，是的，所以你知道，并不是在每种情况下都一样，但在大多数情况下，当然我们已经看到双相情感障碍，它看起来非常像一种治疗。精神科医生就是这样使用它的。至少我们可以选择不同的词，说人们可以通过单独使用营养素来管理他们余生的症状。这就是我们所看到的，人们可以用情绪稳定营养素替代情绪稳定药物，这正是大自然为情绪稳定所意图的，你知道，调节焦虑，好吧，随着
childhood with childhood issues everything's off-label anyway. If you've tried the two or three that are approved to be, you know, treatment-resistant bipolar in children, whatever you're being prescribed is not approved for what they're prescribing for anyway. They have to prescribe off-label because there's not anything there. Why not try the nutrition, you know? It's amazing, Joel.
童年，随着童年问题，一切都是超说明书用药。如果你尝试了那两三种被批准的，你知道，儿童治疗抵抗型双相情感障碍，无论你被开什么药，反正都不是批准用于他们所开的用途。他们必须超说明书开药，因为那里没有什么东西。为什么不尝试营养呢，你知道？这太神奇了，Joel。
Most of the people, I'd say 80% of the people that come to us are on a medication, an antidepressant, antipsychotic, or were just recently on one. So the principle that Jared's talking about, we've learned, it's actually a false positive. So this is what happens if a doctor's not involved and they just go to the internet, find our product, and they're on two or three medications. Let's throw a Fexor in there or Abilify, Wellbutrin, and they start taking our product. They're going to feel okay, maybe a little bit of a placebo. I'm excited to try something different, right? First week, second week.
大多数人，我会说80%来找我们的人都在服用药物，抗抑郁药，抗精神病药，或者最近刚服用过一种。所以Jared谈论的原则，我们已经学到了，它实际上是一个假阳性。所以如果医生不参与，他们只是去互联网，找到我们的产品，而他们正在服用两三种药物，就会发生这种情况。让我们在里面扔一个Effexor或Abilify，Wellbutrin，然后他们开始服用我们的产品。他们会感觉还可以，也许有一点安慰剂效应。我很兴奋尝试不同的东西，对吧？第一周，第二周。
Into the third week, they start feeling groggy and all these symptoms and the brain fog and maybe the electric shocks at the back of the neck, and they're like, what is going on? Well, the only thing I changed is I started taking this expensive vitamin mineral supplement so they stopped taking it and the electric shocks go away and they start thinking it'll bits the hot been that stuff but what is actually happening is if they went to the internet drugs comm rx list comm Google and they type in effects or over-medication side effects. They're going to find all those things that they're experiencing.
到了第三周，他们开始感到昏昏沉沉，所有这些症状和脑雾，也许脖子后面有电击感，他们就像，发生了什么事？好吧，我唯一改变的就是我开始服用这种昂贵的维生素矿物质补充剂，所以他们停止服用它，电击感消失了，他们开始认为这一定是那些东西，但实际上发生的是，如果他们去互联网drugs.com rxlist.com Google，他们输入Effexor过度用药副作用。他们会发现他们正在经历的所有那些事情。
Are you talking about heart of dyskinesia? So what's happening is, yeah, the body's actually producing all the things that it needs for serotonin to occur properly. And it'd be like giving a person that doesn't need medication that medication what are they gonna feel you feel over medicated and so it's an indication that they need to start titrating off slowly some of those meds man you can't just drop them you have to go by one sixteenths one eighths you know and we've learned that over the years our our group has had to learn that and when someone comes to you and they're on 15 medications, which one do you work with first? We know if you're giving them the nutrients that their body needs, their mind, their synapses are going to start firing appropriately. I want to share my screen just for a moment just to kind of demonstrate, and this is well thought, well laid out in science. This is a tryptophan metabolism or serotonin synthesis.
你在谈论迟发性运动障碍吗？所以发生了什么，是的，身体实际上正在产生血清素正常发生所需的所有东西。这就像给一个不需要药物的人那种药物，他们会感觉什么？你感觉用药过量，所以这表明他们需要开始缓慢地滴定减少那些药物，伙计，你不能只是放弃它们，你必须按十六分之一，八分之一，你知道，我们多年来已经学到了这一点，我们的团队不得不学习这一点，当有人来找你，他们正在服用15种药物时，你先处理哪一种？我们知道如果你给他们身体所需的营养素，他们的思想，他们的突触将开始适当地放电。我想分享我的屏幕片刻，只是为了演示，这是经过深思熟虑的，在科学上布局得很好。这是色氨酸代谢或血清素合成。
Keep in mind, some people are going to be on the audio. So if you can just kind of qualify what you're talking about through the visuals, always nice to have for the video. Sure. There's a group of medications called SSRIs. They're selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors. So they're a medication that affects the serotonin pathways. They don't actually make any more. They just sort of stop you from getting rid of what you've already made to keep, you know, a higher level in the brain, which can also cause some issues. And I mean, I'm on an SSRI, like I'm not anti, I just always am afraid of sounding like Alex Jones. I mean, this'm on an SSRI, like I'm not anti, I just always am afraid of sounding like Alex Jones. I mean, this stuff is science. It's not. Sure. But you can see here just in this
请记住，有些人会听音频。所以如果你能通过视觉效果来限定你在谈论什么，总是很高兴为视频准备。当然。有一组药物叫做SSRIs。它们是选择性血清素再摄取抑制剂。所以它们是一种影响血清素通路的药物。它们实际上并没有制造更多。它们只是阻止你摆脱你已经制造的东西，以保持，你知道，大脑中更高的水平，这也可能导致一些问题。我的意思是，我正在服用SSRI，就像我不是反，我只是总是害怕听起来像Alex Jones。我的意思是，这，我正在服用SSRI，就像我不是反，我只是总是害怕听起来像Alex Jones。我的意思是，这些东西是科学。它不是。当然。但你可以看到这里就在这个
pathway, we got a riboflavin, vitamin B6, iron. We've got phosphorus in there. You know, there's a, there's a potassium. These are things that are, that are needed in these pathways in order to strip the fan or serotonin the proper way. When you don't have those things in your body to the proper levels, these are going to suffer. So medications in that sense can come in and help that. But what happens when you're giving your body all that it needs, it's going to start. It's like a map, right? Your body just needs ingredients to follow the map and once it it's not fast uh vitamins and minerals do not happen quick you know quickly but once it starts taking effect and you've still got
通路中，我们有核黄素，维生素B6，铁。我们有磷在里面。你知道，有一个，有一个钾。这些是这些通路中需要的物质，以便以正确的方式剥离色氨酸或血清素。当你体内没有这些东西达到适当水平时，这些就会受损。所以药物在那种意义上可以进来提供帮助。但当你给你的身体它所需要的一切时，它会开始。这就像一张地图，对吧？你的身体只需要成分来遵循地图，一旦它，它不是快，维生素和矿物质不会很快发生，你知道，但一旦它开始生效，而你仍然有
the chemical in there medication in there there's there's a contra you know you've got to choose one or the other um i don't know if I'm explaining that very well, Jared. Yes, this is a critical concept. And I appreciate you delving into this, Corey, because this is so critical to what we do. What we try to do there with all of these medication interaction effects we've dealt with is we work directly with clinicians. We leave the medications as much as possible squarely on the shoulders of the experts who are trained to manage medications. We need to train them about the interaction effects occurring between nutrients and medications. Corey delved into a pharmacodynamic interaction effect. That is, as the nutrients act in the body
化学物质在里面，药物在里面，有一个反，你知道，你必须选择一个或另一个，嗯，我不知道我是否解释得很好，Jared。是的，这是一个关键概念。我很感激你深入研究这一点，Corey，因为这对我们所做的事情至关重要。我们试图在那里处理所有这些我们处理过的药物相互作用效应，我们直接与临床医生合作。我们尽可能将药物完全留在受过管理药物培训的专家的肩上。我们需要培训他们关于营养素和药物之间发生的相互作用效应。Corey深入研究了一种药效学相互作用效应。也就是说，随着营养素在体内发挥作用
to change the underlying issues of the condition, the medication is needed less and less. The body doesn't need as much manipulation when the underlying issues are solved. And so we see that with many... The blend changes, the idea of just a daily multivitamin that works for 100% of the people 100% of the time, no matter what's happening is it's kind of a misnomer. No, and we're not claiming that's happening for sure. No, I mean, what you're saying is, you know, when I'm the first day on trying to change lifestyle and doing micronutrition, once I restart some of these metabolic pathways or
来改变疾病的根本问题，药物的需求越来越少。当根本问题解决时，身体不需要那么多的操纵。所以我们看到很多……混合物会改变，仅仅是一个对100%的人在100%的时间里都有效的日常多种维生素的想法，无论发生什么，这是一种误称。不，我们当然没有声称会发生这种情况。不，我的意思是，你所说的是，你知道，当我第一天尝试改变生活方式并进行微量营养时，一旦我重新启动其中一些代谢通路或
build back up precursors, I mean, a lot of different things, I'm oversimplifying it, but that you're going to need something different a month in, then you're going to need seven months in, which makes sense to me, you know, more so than it works for everything all the time. Yes. So we need to replete individuals who need to be repleted of nutrients for functions to work optimally. And these nutrients are needed in every cell of the body. And they work together naturally. So the synergistic effect of all of the essential nutrients, we're talking about all of the vitamins, all of the essential minerals, omega fatty acids, and amino acids. We supply all of those. The products are produced and distributed in the United States with very high quality ingredients. You talked about bioavailability is evidenced in results. That's what we focus on.
重建前体，我的意思是，很多不同的东西，我过度简化了它，但你一个月后需要的东西，和你七个月后需要的东西是不一样的，这对我来说是有道理的，你知道，比它一直对所有事情都有效更有道理。是的。所以我们需要补充那些需要补充营养素以使功能最佳运作的个体。这些营养素在身体的每个细胞中都是必需的。它们自然地协同工作。所以所有必需营养素的协同效应，我们谈论的是所有的维生素，所有的必需矿物质，欧米茄脂肪酸和氨基酸。我们提供所有这些。这些产品在美国生产和分销，成分质量非常高。你谈到的生物利用度在结果中得到了证明。这就是我们关注的重点。
So the blinded trials, independent of us, none of these are paid for by our company. The researchers are arm's length. They have independent funding. They just publish what they find and it does not show that everyone is miraculously well but the longer people take it with with the blinded trials and the follow-ups from the blinded trials number one it's safe there's there are no side effect differences. You're not going to build tolerance to it. That's unheard of with any psychiatric medication.
所以盲法试验，独立于我们，这些都不是由我们公司支付的。研究人员是独立的。他们有独立的资金。他们只是发布他们发现的东西，它并没有显示每个人都奇迹般地好了，但人们服用它的时间越长，随着盲法试验和盲法试验的后续行动，第一，它是安全的，没有副作用差异。你不会对它产生耐受性。这在任何精神科药物中都是闻所未闻的。
It's a night and day difference in terms of side effects. And for that reason alone, many parents and individuals just prefer it hands down. The stability is greater than what medications can offer actually over time we don't need to find a new treatment because the old one stopped working as it was before and that's a common thing in psychiatric pharmacologic treatment you know it needs careful management. And the nutrients help people manage eventually on their own. They just take nutrients. And there are factors in their lives like sleep and managing stress and so on. They're always relevant.
在副作用方面，这是天壤之别。仅凭这个原因，许多父母和个人就直接更喜欢它。稳定性实际上随着时间的推移比药物所能提供的要高，我们不需要寻找新的治疗方法，因为旧的治疗方法停止了工作，就像以前一样，这是精神科药物治疗中的常见事情，你知道，它需要仔细管理。而营养素帮助人们最终自己管理。他们只是服用营养素。而且他们的生活中还有睡眠和管理压力等因素。它们总是相关的。
Those are always important. Diet. Those are synergistic effects. But when we have a foundation of nutrients, those things are much easier to manage. People can shop for healthy foods, prepare them. They can get out of bed to do this. So it's really critical to have the synergy that we need. Excuse me for a second here. My battery is running low. A lot of what you were showing on that diagram and what you guys are talking about is, you know, the newer, not just nutrition, but, you know, all medications. Now they're doing this for psychoactive medications and to try and see how genetic testing could inform, you know, what you're prescribed. But there is the idea of metabolic pathways, that it isn't just that you take the thing, now it goes into your body, now you have the thing. It's that, you know, there's going to be a tree of, if you have the right thing to combine it with, it's going to react to this, and then you have that thing. So when you're trying
那些总是很重要的。饮食。那些是协同效应。但当我们有营养素的基础时，那些事情就更容易管理了。人们可以购买健康的食物，准备它们。他们可以起床做这件事。所以拥有我们需要的协同作用确实至关重要。请原谅我一下。我的电池快没电了。你在那个图表上展示的很多东西以及你们谈论的东西是，你知道，较新的，不仅仅是营养，而是，你知道，所有药物。现在他们正在为精神活性药物做这件事，并试图看看基因检测如何告知，你知道，你被开了什么药。但有代谢通路的想法，它不仅仅是你吃了那个东西，现在它进入你的身体，现在你有了那个东西。它是，你知道，将有一棵树，如果你有正确的东西与它结合，它会对这个产生反应，然后你就有那个东西。所以当你试图
to control five or six different reactions to make sure it ends up in the right place, you know, that's the science that takes a while and that you have to be careful with. I mean, one example is if a lot of people say, okay, for dopamine disorders, you want to go take huge doses of, you know, B12, and you can't absorb B12 very well orally. So get the kind that stays under your tongue that sublingually goes directly into your blood. Well, you know, the two ways that you can get that are cyanocobalamin and methocobalamin because your body's going to take that and it's going to have a reaction to it. Now, if you're taking cyanocobalamin, which is the cheaper form that's going to be, you know, the store brand a lot of the time, then that is producing cyanide.
控制五六种不同的反应以确保它最终到达正确的地方时，你知道，那是需要一段时间的科学，你必须小心。我的意思是，一个例子是，如果很多人说，好吧，对于多巴胺紊乱，你想去服用大量的，你知道，B12，而你不能很好地口服吸收B12。所以得到那种留在你舌头下面，舌下直接进入你血液的那种。好吧，你知道，你可以得到它的两种方式是氰钴胺和甲钴胺，因为你的身体会服用它，它会对它产生反应。现在，如果你服用氰钴胺，这是更便宜的形式，通常是商店品牌，那么它正在产生氰化物。
And the FDA would say, OK, well, that cyanide that it's making is beneath the level that would matter. So it's fine. But, you know, until I'm caught behind enemy lines, you know, I don't really want to eat cyanide personally. So I'm going to buy the methylcobalamin. But, you know, how many people know this stuff or understand it? I mean, and that's one pathway for a relatively simple vitamin, you know. Oh, did we lose Jared? I think we lost Jared there. But I'll segue off of that to what we were initially talking about. It's true.
FDA会说，好吧，它产生的氰化物含量在可接受范围内，所以没问题。但是，你知道，除非我被困在敌后，否则我个人真的不想吃氰化物。所以我还是会买甲基钴胺素。但是，有多少人了解或明白这些东西呢？我的意思是，这只是相对简单的维生素的一个途径。哦，我们失去Jared了吗？我想我们失去Jared了。但我会从这一点过渡到我们最初讨论的话题。确实如此。
Doctors years ago would say vitamins and minerals don't work. They're just expensive urine, you know. And you can actually see it. It's way more. And I was like, well, my, but man, look, my cholesterol changed. And he was like, wow. But what's, what's, what's different in our product is most multivitamins take just a couple hours in manufacturing. Okay.
多年前医生会说维生素和矿物质没用，它们只是昂贵的尿液。你实际上可以看到，情况远不止于此。我当时说，但是，伙计，你看，我的胆固醇改变了。他当时说，哇。但是我们的产品与众不同之处在于，大多数多种维生素在生产过程中只需要几个小时。好的。
Put together our mineral blend just alone takes several days. And what we do is we take the minerals and we make them so that they're organic in nature, similar to what you find in broccoli. And that's chelation. And we have a special type of chelation. You can get chelated products in the health food store. Usually they're expensive because it's hard. It takes a process to do. Can you explain chelation, the difference in that? Go ahead, Jared, yeah.
单单是配制我们的矿物质混合物就需要几天时间。我们所做的是将矿物质转化为天然的有机形式，类似于你在西兰花中发现的那样。这就是螯合。我们有一种特殊的螯合方式。你可以在保健品店买到螯合产品。通常它们很贵，因为这很难，需要一个过程。你能解释一下螯合以及其中的区别吗？请继续，Jared。
I'll take a stab at that. So there are natural chelators in nature. And what are the process? Just scientifically, chemistry, what is chelation? Yes, so chelators are binding minerals. The stabilizers. And some chelators are very strong chelators. Key laters are binding minerals. Stabilize them. Some key laters are very strong key laters.
我来试着解释一下。自然界中存在天然螯合剂。那么这个过程是什么？从科学和化学的角度来看，什么是螯合？是的，螯合剂是结合矿物质的稳定剂。有些螯合剂是非常强的螯合剂。螯合剂是结合矿物质的稳定剂。有些螯合剂是非常强的螯合剂。
And so they bind minerals and deprive our body of them. You can bind it so strong that your body can't get it off of what you're using to stabilize it. It's like with the yard when you've got, you know, if you do forestry, there's like sand will let the water be pulled out of the ground but it won't hold any water so there's as soon as you dump the water on the plant it's gone clay will hold water for 10 years but the problem is the plant will hold it so well that the plants can't get it out so you need this kind of blend of sand and clay in the middle in order to be stable enough and that's you know the moving target that you guys are trying to hit for the most amount of people the most amount of time. Good analogy.
它们结合矿物质并剥夺我们身体对它们的吸收。你可以结合得非常紧密，以至于你的身体无法从你用来稳定它的物质中获取它。这就像在院子里，如果你做林业，沙子会让水从地里流走，但它留不住水，所以一旦你把水倒在植物上，水就没了；粘土可以保持水分十年，但问题是植物会把它抓得太紧，以至于植物无法获取它，所以你需要这种沙子和粘土的混合物，才能足够稳定，这就是你们试图为最多的人在最长的时间内达到的目标。很好的比喻。
Yeah. Excellent. Yeah. We need a reversible chelation. So it's bound and delivered to the body and the natural chelators do that. There are multiple forms of natural chelators. In fruits, we have malic acid, we have citric acid, we have other organic acids that can serve as chelators. And there are natural chelators in soil as well.
是的。太棒了。是的。我们需要一种可逆的螯合。这样它就能被结合并输送到身体中，天然螯合剂就是这样做的。天然螯合剂有多种形式。在水果中，我们有苹果酸、柠檬酸，我们还有其他可以作为螯合剂的有机酸。土壤中也有天然螯合剂。
And they help the body, the plant rather, uptake minerals. The fungi are, are, you know, breaking down the rock form minerals into forms of the plants can use. All of these natural chelators are quite complex. And we're just trying to recreate that the best we can with our proprietary Nutratech chelation complex. We're creating for all of the minerals. This is just a process for minerals, not vitamins. We're trying to bind the minerals so they can be delivered more optimally to the body. That's the key for bioavailability. And it's bulky.
它们帮助身体，或者说帮助植物吸收矿物质。真菌正在将岩石形式的矿物质分解成植物可以利用的形式。所有这些天然螯合剂都非常复杂。我们只是试图用我们专有的Nutratech螯合复合物尽可能地重现这一点。我们正在为所有的矿物质创造这种复合物。这只是矿物质的加工过程，而不是维生素。我们试图结合矿物质，以便它们能更优化地输送到身体。这就是生物利用度的关键。而且它体积很大。
So the blinded trials are done using 12 capsules per day and the majority of that is is the bulk of macro minerals calcium phosphorus magnesium there's just one way to make it small we're delivering yeah our bodies need them in gram amounts every day and so it takes quite a few capsules to deliver those. But they're effective. For example, magnesium has a lot of overlap in mechanisms, an astounding overlap in mechanisms with lithium. And lithium is used as a mood stabilizer, and has been for decades in psychiatry. You know, we replace lithium entirely in most cases. In some cases, people use less than 20 milligrams of lithium together with the daily essential nutrients.
所以盲法试验是每天使用12粒胶囊，其中大部分是大量宏量矿物质，如钙、磷、镁，只有一种方法能让它变小，我们正在输送，是的，我们的身体每天需要克级的这些物质，所以需要相当多的胶囊来输送它们。但它们很有效。例如，镁在机制上有很多重叠，与锂在机制上有惊人的重叠。锂被用作情绪稳定剂，在精神病学中已经使用了几十年。你知道，在大多数情况下，我们完全用镁替代了锂。在某些情况下，人们将少于20毫克的锂与日常必需营养素一起使用。
And I'm talking about psychiatrists. It's useful. Lithium, we have a very small amount of lithium in our product, one milligram in those 12 capsules that have been studied. And that's about as much as people will get in food and water each day. We have some lithium that we intake every day. And there's some fascinating research about how that helps with mood stabilization. So we're treating it as a trace mineral. But magnesium seems to do the bulk of the job.
我说的是精神科医生。这很有用。锂，我们的产品中含有极少量的锂，在研究的12粒胶囊中只有1毫克。这大约是人们每天从食物和水中摄入的量。我们每天都会摄入一些锂。关于它如何帮助稳定情绪，有一些非常迷人的研究。所以我们把它当作微量矿物质来对待。但镁似乎完成了大部分工作。
Lithium in pharmacologic levels, as used in psychiatry, seems to be a poor substitute, if I can say it that way, for the designed action of magnesium. So as soon as we start giving the body the levels of magnesium that really take care of that mood stabilization in a more effective way, people feel like themselves. With lithium, they don't. They have plenty of side effects. They feel headaches and tremor. It's difficult to find just the right level and to have them feel like themselves. With magnesium, with the full set of nutrients, I should say,
精神病学中使用的药理学水平的锂，如果我可以这样说的话，似乎是镁的预期作用的一个糟糕的替代品。所以一旦我们开始给身体提供真正能以更有效方式处理情绪稳定的镁水平，人们就会感觉像他们自己。而使用锂，他们不会。他们有大量的副作用。他们感到头痛和震颤。很难找到合适的水平并让他们感觉像他们自己。而使用镁，或者说全套营养素，
including magnesium, we, it's critical to have a balance of magnesium and calcium, sodium, potassium, our bodies are designed to have these nutrients from food and they're present in a natural balance. You know, there's a reasonable balance that soils and plants throughout the world will give us. In some places, for example, iodine is deficient in soil that needs to be supplemented somehow. Or, you you know we need to have foods from other areas where the iodine is not deficient in order to avoid deficiency of iodine similar with selenium and with other trace minerals so it helps to have a broad variety of foods in our diet to meet all these needs that's kind of that's what we're doing with the nutrients we're ensuring that the body has all of these nutrients at recommended levels and it they function so that's the synergy aspect
包括镁，保持镁、钙、钠、钾的平衡至关重要，我们的身体被设计为从食物中获取这些营养素，它们以自然的平衡存在。你知道，世界各地的土壤和植物会给我们一个合理的平衡。在某些地方，例如，土壤中缺乏碘，需要以某种方式补充。或者，你知道，我们需要从其他碘不缺乏的地区获取食物，以避免碘缺乏，硒和其他微量矿物质也是如此，所以饮食中拥有广泛的食物种类来满足所有这些需求是有帮助的，这就是我们用营养素所做的事情，我们确保身体在推荐水平上拥有所有这些营养素，它们发挥作用，这就是协同效应。
that you asked um if we could address um you know you could think of the the functions of the body working together like a dam holding back water. When the dam leaks and breaks, our level of function is lowered in different ways. in our research is look at the number of people who don't meet just the minimum requirements to avoid deficiency disorders. That's the recommended dietary allowance. And that's only good for 97 to 98% of individuals in theory. They estimate an average need, they go up a couple of standard deviations, and in theory, that will meet the needs of 97 to 98% of apparently healthy individuals. What we believe from our experience, we're working with the tail of that bell curve. So people who are not meeting their needs, even at rda levels yeah but the reality is not people many people are not even getting the rda levels and so it's not just that two percent of people who are deficient
你问我们是否可以讨论这个问题，你可以把身体的功能想象成一个拦水的大坝。当大坝泄漏和破裂时，我们的功能水平会以不同的方式降低。我们的研究着眼于那些甚至达不到避免缺乏症最低要求的人数。这就是推荐膳食摄入量（RDA）。理论上，这只对97%到98%的个体有效。他们估计了一个平均需求，向上加了几个标准差，理论上，这将满足97%到98%的明显健康个体的需求。根据我们的经验，我们认为我们正在处理钟形曲线的尾端。所以那些没有满足需求的人，即使在RDA水平上，是的，但现实是很多人甚至没有达到RDA水平，所以不仅仅是那2%的人缺乏
in these nutrients and it's not just one nutrient they're deficient in they're chronically low in these nutrients. And so it becomes really useful to use a supplement to top up these levels. The Institute of Medicine in creating these levels stated that the RDA would not be deemed sufficient to replete individuals previously undernourished. That's the situation we have in our countries. We eat a lot of calories, but they're often nutrient poor calories, not nutrient dense. And so, you know, it's a slower process. We could try to eat more nutrient dense foods to replete ourselves. And that's useful still, absolutely useful. But it helps to pop up these essential nutrients with a supplement. It happens more quickly from our experience.
这些营养素，而且他们缺乏的不仅仅是一种营养素，他们长期缺乏这些营养素。因此，使用补充剂来补充这些水平变得非常有用。医学研究所（Institute of Medicine）在制定这些水平时指出，RDA不足以补充之前营养不良的个体。这就是我们国家的情况。我们摄入了很多热量，但它们通常是营养贫乏的热量，而不是营养密集型的。所以，你知道，这是一个缓慢的过程。我们可以尝试吃更多营养密集的食物来补充自己。这仍然很有用，绝对有用。但用补充剂来补充这些必需营养素会有所帮助。根据我们的经验，这发生得更快。
And then people can manage with an improved diet much more effectively. We find people's needs for the nutrients are variable depending on the nature of their diet, the nature of gut health, nature of genetics. Some people have a higher genetic need for certain nutrients, and that's reflected in what the Institute of Medicine displays as a bell curve of nutrient needs. Some people, you know, the majority of people need that average need that they estimate, and some people need higher than that. And so in a famine, some people will fare better than others. We've seen this in real life. In the Dutch famine, for example,
然后人们可以更有效地通过改善饮食来管理。我们发现人们对营养素的需求是可变的，取决于他们的饮食性质、肠道健康状况、遗传性质。有些人对某些营养素有更高的遗传需求，这反映在医学研究所显示的营养需求钟形曲线上。有些人，你知道，大多数人需要他们估计的平均需求，而有些人需要比这更高的需求。所以在大饥荒中，有些人会比其他人过得更好。我们在现实生活中已经看到了这一点。例如，在荷兰饥荒中，
there were higher rates of mental disorders documented. It's well documented there. And who had those mental disorders? Presumably, those who are more genetically susceptible or who have poor gut health. And of course, those who did not have quite as good a diet. What they're eating may not have been quite as nutrient dense. Can you extrapolate a little bit, Jared, for those that are listening and might not understand what happened in Holland, World War II, and why that happened? Yeah, so I think it's a useful case study for what's happening in a larger way in our society. You know, we think of a situation of famine. And we think, you know, that's, that's extreme. None of us are starving. Right. But we are starving for
记录在案的精神障碍发病率更高。那里有充分的记录。谁患有这些精神障碍？据推测，那些遗传上更易感或肠道健康状况较差的人。当然，那些饮食不太好的人。他们吃的东西可能营养密度不够。Jared，你能为那些正在收听且可能不了解二战期间荷兰发生了什么以及为什么发生这种情况的人稍微推断一下吗？是的，所以我认为这是一个关于我们社会中正在发生的大规模事件的有用案例研究。你知道，我们想到饥荒的情况。我们认为，那是极端的。我们没有人挨饿。对。但我们正在为
essential nutrients. That's what many people don't realize. The calories in one sixth of total calories in the United States of America is from sugars. There are zero nutrients in those refined sugars. So all of us immediately, that's one sixth of our total calories. Yeah. More than that. Not contributing to our nutrient needs. And then there are added fats in addition to that. Those are very calorie dense and nutrient poor when they're refined. So what we really need is the whole food with the nutrient dense minerals and vitamins from those plants. Well, and we evolved to seek out things that contained salt sugar and fat and then yes because of starvation and ice ages and droughts where we needed to carry weight and
必需营养素而挨饿。这就是许多人没有意识到的。美国总热量的六分之一来自糖。这些精制糖中没有任何营养。所以我们所有人立即，这是我们总热量的六分之一。是的。不止于此。对我们的营养需求没有贡献。此外还有添加的脂肪。当它们被精制时，这些热量非常高，但营养贫乏。所以我们真正需要的是全食物，以及来自这些植物的营养密集的矿物质和维生素。嗯，我们进化到寻找含有盐、糖和脂肪的东西，然后是的，因为饥荒、冰河时代和干旱，我们需要携带体重，并且
now we're in a position where you know we can just pull salt sugar and fat out of any vending machine and all of a sudden um you know what our what our what our body feels like it wants is not actually what it needs and to explain the complexity of what you guys are doing, it's like, you know, if the car is reliable, you know, human, humanity is on every continent other than Antarctica. I mean, we're one of the most diverse and what we're able to, you know, as a species and what we're able to live through and live on and live around, you know, and so the genes are different globally because, you know,
现在我们处于一种位置，你知道，我们可以从任何自动售货机中取出盐、糖和脂肪，突然之间，嗯，你知道，我们的身体感觉它想要的东西实际上并不是它所需要的。为了解释你们正在做的事情的复杂性，这就像，你知道，如果汽车是可靠的，你知道，人类在南极洲以外的每个大陆上都有。我的意思是，我们是最多样化的物种之一，我们能够，你知道，作为一个物种，我们能够经历、生活和生存，你知道，所以基因在全球范围内是不同的，因为，你知道，
people live in different areas and now, you know, we can get on airplanes. All of a sudden, you know, and so the genes are different globally because, you know, people live in different areas and now, you know, we can get on airplanes all of a sudden, you know, it's not like you can feed everyone in this one region. Like they evolved the same, you know, if somebody needs to be able to synthesize vitamin D and they're from Norway, their skin is a little bit lighter. If that's where the gene pool came from, then somebody who needed to protect against skin cancer and block out the sun and have more melanin in their skin, you know, in the equatorial place, you know, so there's all that together. And you're trying to say, okay, this works for the most people, the most of the time I'm suspicious of anybody that says their thing works for everybody all the time. That's kind of, you catch the grip. Um,
人们生活在不同的地区，现在，你知道，我们可以坐飞机。突然之间，你知道，所以基因在全球范围内是不同的，因为，你知道，人们生活在不同的地区，现在，你知道，我们可以坐飞机，突然之间，你知道，并不是说你可以喂养这个地区的所有人。就像他们进化得一样，你知道，如果有人需要能够合成维生素D，而他们来自挪威，他们的皮肤会稍微浅一点。如果这就是基因库的来源，那么那些需要预防皮肤癌、阻挡阳光并在皮肤中有更多黑色素的人，你知道，在赤道地区，你知道，所以这一切都在一起。而你试图说，好吧，这适用于大多数人，大多数时间。我怀疑任何说他们的东西总是适用于所有人的人。这有点，你抓住了重点。嗯，
and you're trying to make that work, but that is complicated because just because we're living and alive and whatever, it doesn't really mean we're getting what we need. I mean, like you can take a Toyota Camry or a geo tracker and just, you know, beat the hell out of it and never change the belt and never change the oil and probably get 250,000 miles on it. You know, the radio doesn't work or whatever, but you can do that to the car and it's still going, but it, you know, it is the car as a person metaphor. like we don't feel good we don't think clearly we're not in a good mood we're not achieving our potential right um we're not treating our mental health we're spending all this money on therapy we're spending all this money on
你试图让它发挥作用，但这很复杂，因为仅仅因为我们活着，无论如何，并不意味着我们得到了我们需要的东西。我的意思是，就像你可以拿一辆丰田凯美瑞或Geo Tracker，然后，你知道，狠狠地开它，从不换皮带，从不换油，可能还能跑25万英里。你知道，收音机坏了什么的，但你可以那样对待汽车，它还在跑，但它，你知道，这就是汽车作为人的隐喻。就像我们感觉不好，我们思考不清晰，我们情绪不好，我们没有发挥我们的潜力，对，嗯，我们没有治疗我们的心理健康，我们把所有的钱都花在治疗上，我们把所有的钱都花在
whiskey we're spending money on weed yes you know and then those have some secondary effects too that we treat a top level symptom but make the bottom level symptom worse right that's worse yeah i love that so much love that analogy so i wanted to go a step further with this and talk about salmon in our day glyphosate roundup in farming is just poured on crops yeah glyosulfate there's essentially there's studies where one third of a pound of glyphosate runs into lake erie for example from every acre in the lake erie watershed every year it's it's poured onto the land on crops and and there's it's sprayed on even spot treat anymore i mean just so people are familiar with what this works round Roundup is glyosulfate, and glyosulfate is cancer for plants. What you were doing was making cells mutate, just like cancer, to where there is no more, what's it called? There's no more telomere on the cell. And so it is just replicating until the plant kills itself with tumors.
威士忌上，我们把钱花在杂草上，是的，你知道，然后这些也有一些次要的影响，我们治疗了顶层症状，但让底层症状变得更糟，对，那更糟，是的，我非常喜欢那个比喻，所以我想要更进一步，谈谈我们今天的草甘膦，农业中的Roundup（农达）只是倒在作物上，是的，草甘膦，本质上是有研究表明，例如，在伊利湖流域，每英亩土地每年有三分之一磅的草甘膦流入伊利湖，它被倒在土地上的作物上，而且它甚至不再是点状喷洒了，我的意思是，为了让人们熟悉它的工作原理，Roundup是草甘膦，而草甘膦对植物来说是癌症。你所做的是让细胞突变，就像癌症一样，以至于不再有，它叫什么？细胞上不再有端粒。所以它只是在复制，直到植物因肿瘤而自杀。
So that's how you kill plants, which we used to say, okay, well, if there's a little weed in your yard, you get the spray bottle and spray it on it. We don't do that anymore. Okay. What we do now is we say we're going to grow Roundup Ready crops that Monsanto owns. There is a patent on that seed. So if you go and pick some of the seeds off that corn, you just broke patent law because the Supreme Court has said that you can patent life now, which is kind of an insane thing. And so this, they own that genetic structure and you cannot be a farmer and make any money unless you're growing this potato, this corn.
所以这就是你杀死植物的方法，我们过去常说，好吧，如果你的院子里有一点杂草，你就拿喷雾瓶喷它。我们不再那样做了。好的。我们现在所做的是说我们要种植孟山都拥有的Roundup Ready作物。该种子有专利。所以如果你去摘一些玉米种子，你就违反了专利法，因为最高法院已经说你现在可以为生命申请专利，这有点疯狂。所以这个，他们拥有那种遗传结构，除非你种植这种土豆、这种玉米，否则你不能成为农民并赚到钱。
So it's all the same thing that you're eating, right? And we don't spot treat weeds. What they do is they grow Roundup Ready plants whose DNA have been developed to resist this poison that causes plant cancer. And then we pour it on all of it. And you're lit. Yes. Just because it was genetically resistant to the crap. That's our system.
所以你吃的所有东西都是一样的，对吧？而且我们不点状处理杂草。他们所做的是种植Roundup Ready植物，其DNA已被开发出来以抵抗这种导致植物癌症的毒药。然后我们把它倒在所有东西上。而你被点亮了。是的。仅仅因为它在基因上对这种垃圾有抵抗力。这就是我们的系统。
Right. And people... Sorry. Sorry to interrupt. I've been interrupting you guys a lot. Like non-GMO foods. And that's a good thing in this situation. You know, we don't want, and what we really want, though, is Roundup free foods. Because there are non-GMO crops that are also sprayed with Roundup right before harvest.
对。人们……抱歉。抱歉打断你们。我一直在打断你们。比如非转基因食品。在这种情况下这是一件好事。你知道，我们不想要，但我们真正想要的是无Roundup食品。因为有些非转基因作物在收获前也被喷洒了Roundup。
Fields of oats and wheat. And those are staple crops. Even if we're trying to eat a good whole food diet, including those whole grains, we could be depriving ourselves of minerals in a significant way because glyphosate, the active ingredient there is a patented mineral chelator. That's what it was first patented for.
燕麦和小麦田。这些是主食作物。即使我们试图吃健康的饮食，包括那些全谷物，我们也可能在很大程度上剥夺了自己的矿物质，因为草甘膦，其中的活性成分是一种专利矿物质螯合剂。这就是它最初被申请专利的原因。
It's very effective. Speaking with a plant pathologist from Purdue University who spent his career after World War II researching the effects of these sprays on plants, he made a very fascinating statement. This is Dr. Don Huber. And he's done some fascinating research and presented some of this information about glyphosate and its damaging effects.
它非常有效。与一位普渡大学的植物病理学家交谈，他在二战后花费了整个职业生涯研究这些喷雾剂对植物的影响，他发表了一个非常迷人的声明。这就是Don Huber博士。他做了一些迷人的研究，并展示了一些关于草甘膦及其破坏性影响的信息。
Much of that research is not his own, but he's compiled it and presented it. He made a very interesting statement based on his personal career, his own career researching plants and the chemicals the chemical effects on plants he said i don't know of any herbicide that's not a mineral chelator that's a incredibly important statement in my mind too like it's not it is it isn't uh um it is not a pesticide that is not uptaken into the plant's system. It is. So whether or not the plant dies of plant cancer doesn't mean it's not in there chelating things.
大部分研究不是他自己的，但他汇编并展示了它。根据他个人的职业生涯，他自己研究植物以及化学物质对植物的化学影响，他发表了一个非常有趣的声明，他说我不知道有什么除草剂不是矿物质螯合剂，这在我看来也是一个极其重要的声明，就像它不是，它不是，它不是一种没有被植物系统吸收的杀虫剂。它是。所以无论植物是否死于植物癌症，并不意味着它不在那里螯合东西。
And you're, you're saying, I was saying glyosulfate later, cause I'm running into the problem that I had when I was like eight, where I was like reading above my reading level. So I'd say subtle. Cause I was reading things that I hadn't heard people say, you know, I didn't know how to pronounce it. So, you know, you curl't know how to pronounce it. So, you know, you curl up with scientific journals by the fire. That's the other thing that makes me frustrated is the people who send me
而你，你正在说，我一直在说草甘膦，因为我遇到了我八岁时遇到的问题，当时我的阅读水平高于我的阅读水平。所以我说微妙。因为我读的东西我没听过别人说，你知道，我不知道怎么发音。所以，你知道，你不知道怎么发音。所以，你知道，你在火边蜷缩着看科学期刊。这就是另一件让我感到沮丧的事情，那些给我发
emails saying that I don't know how to read research, typically read less research than I read. But so I'm anyway, thank you for correcting me because I read this stuff, but there's not a ton of people that are willing to talk about it with me. My wife. Yeah, no problem. The concept is what's really important. And that is, you know, when we're intaking the sprays that are depleting us of minerals on a daily basis, we have a famine. We have a very real famine of minerals, essential minerals that we need. And so that's in addition to food choices.
电子邮件说我不知道如何阅读研究的人，通常读的研究比我读的少。但所以无论如何，谢谢你纠正我，因为我读这些东西，但没有多少人愿意和我谈论它。我妻子。是的，没问题。这个概念才是真正重要的。那就是，你知道，当我们每天摄入那些剥夺我们矿物质的喷雾剂时，我们就会发生饥荒。我们有一种非常真实的矿物质饥荒，我们需要必需矿物质。所以这除了食物选择之外。
So we're already cutting out a lot of minerals by refined flour, for example, by added sugars and fats in our foods. And we need these minerals for function. What we're finding is we're just getting to that threshold like in the dutch famine where people can't handle such a low level of nutrition that's what we seem to see people we don't know what's making us sick we think we need more pills and and it's not even like we need a supplement or something we just need food we need nutrients right there's all those nutrients in the cell it's not like okay well you need Hornet venom because you're low on whatever. It's just like your body is designed to have a lot of micronutrients doing things in cell walls and microglia in myelin, uh, in your liver. And if you don't have that, you feel bad and you keep
所以我们已经通过精制面粉，例如，通过食物中添加的糖和脂肪，切断了很多矿物质。我们需要这些矿物质来发挥功能。我们发现我们只是达到了那个阈值，就像在荷兰饥荒中一样，人们无法处理如此低水平的营养，这就是我们似乎看到的情况，人们不知道是什么让我们生病，我们认为我们需要更多的药丸，而这甚至不像我们需要补充剂什么的，我们只是需要食物，我们需要营养，对，细胞里有所有这些营养素，并不是说，好吧，你需要黄蜂毒液，因为你缺乏什么。这只是你的身体被设计为在细胞壁、小胶质细胞、髓鞘、你的肝脏中有很多微量营养素在起作用。如果你没有那个，你感觉很糟糕，你一直
being like, Oh, I need to go to gym. I need to go to therapy and buy this product. And it's, it's not that it's just ground up. If you don't have this stuff in your body you can't make cells work it's what we're made out of like if you were to boil us down you get a bunch of water and you'd have a little pile of what what is that and you know our body is made out of it so if you give your body the ingredients that it's made out of it has a map in it and it will we find that it repairs itself over time like if you cut yourself the body is going to send some white blood cells it's going to create a right it's good it knows what to do but the body needs the ingredients and we're not we're not anti-pharma but you know uh abilify a body like that's not like what if you boil it down like that's not what it's made out.
像，哦，我需要去健身房。我需要去治疗，买这个产品。而它，它不是那样的，它只是被磨碎了。如果你身体里没有这些东西，你就不能让细胞工作，这就是我们构成的，就像如果你把我们煮沸，你会得到一堆水，你会有一小堆，那是什么，你知道，我们的身体就是由它构成的，所以如果你给你的身体它构成的成分，它里面有一张地图，它会，我们发现它会随着时间的推移自我修复，就像如果你割伤自己，身体会发送一些白细胞，它会创造一个，对，它很好，它知道该怎么做，但身体需要成分，而我们不是，我们不是反制药的，但你知道，嗯，阿立哌唑，像那样的身体，那不像，如果你像那样把它煮沸，那不是它构成的。
And when you give your body what it's made out of and it starts to fix itself and start getting all these neural pathways going, the synapses start firing properly. It's a wonderful thing to see. Jared says they start feeling like themselves. Normal. Yes. You know, it's yes. People feel like they come out of a fog they they have clarity of mind they have stable moods you know they're still of course the
当你给你的身体它构成的东西，它开始自我修复并开始让所有这些神经通路运转，突触开始正常放电。看到这一点是一件美妙的事情。Jared说他们开始感觉像他们自己。正常。是的。你知道，它是，是的。人们感觉他们从迷雾中走出来，他们有清晰的头脑，他们有稳定的情绪，你知道，当然还有
regular emotions that we feel it doesn't blunt emotion like people describe with medication with psychiatric medications in many cases but you know it's just great to have the option. You know, we're not anti-medication, but many people choose to give the nutrients a try and even try them first before medications. And we found that that's very useful. And, you know, so... When you're ready for therapy, you're ready for therapy when your brain is working. I mean, it's like so much of the stuff that's environmental, I can't really change. And
我们感受到的常规情绪，它不会像人们描述的那样，在许多情况下使用精神药物会钝化情绪，但你知道，有这个选择真是太好了。你知道，我们不是反药物的，但许多人选择尝试营养素，甚至在药物之前先尝试它们。我们发现这非常有用。而且，你知道，所以……当你准备好接受治疗时，当你的大脑工作时，你就准备好接受治疗了。我的意思是，就像这么多环境方面的东西，我真的无法改变。而且
even brain-based medicine, which is working on the brain's desire for, you know, the parasympathetic and sympathetic to re-sync and this, you know, to get trauma out of the sub-brain. I mean, what's the thing that all the brain-based medicine practitioners tell you if you go do QEG brain mapping or neurostimulation, or you go do brain spotting, or you go do emotional transformation therapies, drink a lot of water, you know, increase neuroplasticity, get some rest, drink water, eat healthy for the next 12 hours so that you're, you can actually build new neural net connections. Yes. Yes. In that way, I'll go a step further here. So we've talked about vitamins and minerals, and it's pretty clear based on what's happened in a in on a large scale that we need minerals we've seen that those are key in therapy we find amino acids enhance
甚至基于大脑的医学，它正在致力于大脑对，你知道，副交感神经和交感神经重新同步的渴望，以及这个，你知道，将创伤从子大脑中清除。我的意思是，如果你去做QEG大脑映射或神经刺激，或者你去进行大脑定位，或者你去进行情绪转化疗法，所有基于大脑的医学从业者告诉你的事情是什么，多喝水，你知道，增加神经可塑性，休息一下，喝水，在接下来的12小时内吃得健康，这样你就可以，你实际上可以建立新的神经网络连接。是的。是的。那样的话，我在这里再进一步。所以我们谈到了维生素和矿物质，基于大规模发生的事情，很明显我们需要矿物质，我们已经看到这些是治疗的关键，我们发现氨基酸也能增强
effects as well so we we try to provide provide a foundation of all the essential nutrients for human needs and and so we have the vitamins and minerals in our daily essential nutrients product. We add omega fatty acids to ensure the brain has those. Those are essential. And then we add amino acids, especially when there's healing to be done in the body. When the body's expressing genes and needing to change receptors. That's all the work of amino acids. So what we've done is we've adopted another aspect of nature. We've tried to just go right straight to nature.
效果，所以我们试图提供人类需求的所有必需营养素的基础，所以我们在日常必需营养素产品中添加了维生素和矿物质。我们添加了欧米茄脂肪酸以确保大脑拥有这些。这些是必需的。然后我们添加氨基酸，特别是在身体需要愈合时。当身体表达基因并需要改变受体时。这些都是氨基酸的工作。所以我们所做的是我们采用了自然的另一个方面。我们试图直接走向自然。
And what we've done is we've combined free form amino acids, both the essential ones and the non-essential ones, in the same ratios as in mother's milk. And the remarkable thing about this is when we did the research, mother's milk in Thailand and Japan and Europe and Africa is almost identical in amino acids, very little variation. It's by design. It's a level of amino acids for human needs. And so we just decided we can't find anything better than that. So we're giving that ratio of amino acids in a pill, and people use it for healing from concussions, healing from trauma. And we rely on practitioners doing the work of therapy to get those neurons connecting. Just the nutrients by themselves, in this case, you could see, are not enough. We need to fire those neurons together and wire them together. The firing happens with therapy and the wiring happens with the help of amino acids.
我们所做的是，我们将游离氨基酸，包括必需的和非必需的，以与母乳中相同的比例结合起来。关于这一点，最了不起的是，当我们进行研究时，泰国、日本、非洲和欧洲的母乳在氨基酸方面几乎相同，几乎没有变化。这是设计使然。这是人类需求水平的氨基酸。所以我们只是决定我们找不到比这更好的东西了。所以我们正在药丸中提供那种比例的氨基酸，人们用它来从脑震荡中愈合，从创伤中愈合。我们依靠从业者进行治疗工作，让那些神经元连接起来。仅靠营养素，在这种情况下，你可以看到，是不够的。我们需要让那些神经元一起放电并将它们连接在一起。放电发生在治疗中，而连接发生在氨基酸的帮助下。
As well as vitamins and minerals and omega fatty acids, they all need to be there. We're not just choosing one among these, and that's key to the outcome. I don't want to take up y'all's whole day with this. We really appreciate you sitting down and giving information, you know, that helps people make a more informed decision about different things. But can you say anything about microglia? Have you looked at any of the newer research on the brain mechanisms that looks like maybe Alzheimer's and different things, why some of the things that work work and why some of the things that we will invent in the future might work better for brain health or like
以及维生素、矿物质和欧米茄脂肪酸，它们都需要在那里。我们不仅仅是在这些中选择一个，这是结果的关键。我不想占用你们一整天的时间。我们非常感谢你们坐下来提供信息，你知道，这有助于人们对不同的事情做出更明智的决定。但你能说点关于小胶质细胞的事情吗？你有没有看过任何关于大脑机制的较新研究，看起来可能像阿尔茨海默病和不同的事情，为什么一些有效的事情有效，以及为什么我们将来发明的一些事情可能对大脑健康更有效，或者像
myelin in the brain, anything with the neuroplasticity, are you familiar with those? Right. So I'll just speak in more general terms here. The glial cells are providing support for those neurons, nutritional support. And where is that coming from? Well, you need to have it in your body in the first place. And then those cells will function as they should. You know, we focus on neurons a lot, but there's a lot happening there.
大脑中的髓鞘，任何关于神经可塑性的东西，你熟悉这些吗？对。所以我在这里只用更通用的术语来说。胶质细胞正在为那些神经元提供支持，营养支持。那来自哪里？好吧，你首先需要在你的身体里拥有它。然后那些细胞就会像它们应该的那样发挥作用。你知道，我们非常关注神经元，但那里发生了很多事情。
So I would just say in general terms, we're just providing the raw materials. The body does its magic. It would be fascinating to see what changes come in scanning studies, in brain mapping. We have the QAG Brain Mapping Clinic. We are looking in the future. I mean, I'm not anywhere where you can do it now, but Deanna and Jay don't have the aversion to academia and publishing that I have. They both have dual degrees, PhD, whatever.
所以我只想说，总的来说，我们只是提供原材料。身体会施展它的魔法。看看扫描研究、大脑映射中会出现什么变化将是迷人的。我们有QAG大脑映射诊所。我们正在展望未来。我的意思是，我不在任何你可以现在做的地方，但Deanna和Jay没有我对学术界和出版的厌恶。他们都有双学位，博士，什么的。
And so it may be something in the future we could start to look at. Does the key change just with supplementation? Yes future we could start to look at. Does the QE change just with supplementation? Yes, we'd love to do that. We are open to research with our supplements and others. We've worked with clinics doing QEG, and they find patterns that change the nutrients so that they can find, they can identify patients for whom the nutrients will work very well. And it's a broad set of patients based on the patterns they're finding the nutrients. And it's not going to hurt, you know,
所以这可能是我们将来可以开始研究的事情。关键是否仅仅通过补充就改变了？是的，将来我们可以开始研究。关键是否仅仅通过补充就改变了？是的，我们很乐意这样做。我们对使用我们的补充剂和其他人的研究持开放态度。我们已经与进行QEG的诊所合作，他们发现了改变营养素的模式，以便他们可以找到，他们可以识别营养素将非常有效的患者。这是一个基于他们发现营养素模式的广泛患者群体。而且它不会造成伤害，你知道，
it's not going to hurt them. You know, there's not a doubt if you try it and it doesn't help you, then stop taking it. I mean, it's not like you're going to withdraw. It's not going to hurt them. You know, there's not a down, if you try it and it doesn't help you, then stop taking it. I mean, it's not like you're going to withdraw. It's not, there's, there's not a huge downside. Um, and you know, it's expensive nutrients, but there's not a giant initial investment, you know, like there are with some of these other things. And you guys were talking about people who are able to go in and then, you know, tear down off of, you know, some mood stabilizers and antipsychotics, you know, or, you know, mood stabilizers and antidepressants. But it's like, how much of that is just a total misdiagnosis anyway, that you're skipping when somebody is coming to treat it that way, instead of going through the doctor, getting on the drug, doing this. I mean, how much of it
它不会伤害他们。你知道，如果你尝试了它，它没有帮助你，那就停止服用。我的意思是，这不像你会戒断。它不会伤害他们。你知道，没有下降，如果你尝试了它，它没有帮助你，那就停止服用。我的意思是，这不像你会戒断。它不是，没有，没有巨大的缺点。嗯，而且你知道，它是昂贵的营养素，但没有巨大的初始投资，你知道，就像其他一些事情一样。你们在谈论那些能够进入，然后，你知道，拆除，你知道，一些情绪稳定剂和抗精神病药，你知道，或者，你知道，情绪稳定剂和抗抑郁药。但就像，当有人以那种方式来治疗它时，你跳过了多少完全误诊的情况，而不是通过医生，服用药物，做这个。我的意思是，它有多少
isn't even the nutrition as much as that you didn't have? Because I mean, like when I was first starting out, you know, we have kind of a pretty specific referral pathway now, but when I was first starting out, I would get referrals from psychiatrists that are like, this person's on a horse dose of antidepressants. It's an 80 pound woman. I can't put her on anymore. You know, I mean, this is kind of my proverbial, obviously they're not on, you know, a horse dose of medication, but they're like, I can't raise that, you know, sedative anymore. So you need to go to a therapist for anxiety. Well, what goes on in your house? What's your routine look like? Well, my husband beats me. Okay. Well, I'm not going to do Zen meditation while you're experiencing domestic abuse. We can talk about why you're, uh, you don't feel like you
甚至不是营养，而是你没有？因为我的意思是，就像我刚开始的时候，你知道，我们现在有一种相当具体的转诊途径，但当我刚开始的时候，我会从精神科医生那里得到转诊，他们说，这个人正在服用马剂量的抗抑郁药。这是一个80磅重的女人。我不能再给她服用了。你知道，我的意思是，这是我的谚语，显然他们没有服用，你知道，马剂量的药物，但他们说，我不能再提高那个，你知道，镇静剂了。所以你需要去看治疗师治疗焦虑。好吧，你家里发生了什么？你的日常工作是什么样的？好吧，我丈夫打我。好吧，我不会在你经历家庭虐待时做禅修。我们可以谈谈为什么你，嗯，你不觉得你
can get out of this situation or you don't think you deserve to, or we can talk about practically what you can do. And, you know, we have referrals for different things to support you and education about the cycle balance, all this stuff, right. That is the right way to go. And we're medicating that because somebody said, are you anxious? Check. Is the anxiety show up this way? Check. All right. DSM five definition, Matt, moving on. Like the environment is the, which I mean, the DSM says you should check the environment, but they don't do it um you know and yes and we're so quick to medicate that person who goes yeah you know you're looking at um all the things that the doctor is not checking for like what's going on with their body what's going on there um yes so a lot of this anyway short version is a ton of people on these medications it's not appropriate
能摆脱这种情况，或者你不认为你值得，或者我们可以谈谈实际上你可以做什么。而且，你知道，我们有针对不同事情的转诊来支持你，以及关于周期平衡的教育，所有这些东西，对。那是正确的方向。而我们正在用药物治疗它，因为有人说，你焦虑吗？勾选。焦虑是以这种方式表现出来的吗？勾选。好吧。DSM 5定义，Matt，继续。就像环境是，我的意思是，DSM说你应该检查环境，但他们不这样做，嗯，你知道，是的，我们太快给那个说“是的，你知道，你正在看，嗯，医生没有检查的所有事情，比如他们的身体发生了什么，那里发生了什么，嗯，是的，所以无论如何，简短的版本是，大量服用这些药物的人，它不适合
for them or they don't even need it. They just need to talk to somebody. We do medication first and therapy later if you run out, if the medication doesn't work. Half the people that go to effective therapy need less or they don't need the medication. We've had to create a support center over the years, kind of like a call center, and teach staff to talk about a few things to help them along. And the other side of our business is scientists like Jared, Taryn, and Dallin. They teach doctors. So doctors will come in, and they'll ask their questions. We'll consult with them.
他们，或者他们甚至不需要它。他们只需要和某人谈谈。我们先用药物，如果用完了，如果药物不起作用，再进行治疗。去接受有效治疗的人中有一半需要更少的药物，或者他们根本不需要药物。多年来，我们不得不建立一个支持中心，有点像呼叫中心，并教员工谈论一些事情来帮助他们。我们业务的另一面是像Jared、Taryn和Dallin这样的科学家。他们教医生。所以医生会进来，他们会问他们的问题。我们将咨询他们。
We have modules that we just teach the ABC principles that we've learned over the last 23 years. They're not difficult, but they're not taught in universities. They just aren't, at least to the extent that we've learned over the last 23 years. They're not difficult, but they're not taught in universities. They just aren't, at least to the extent that we teach them. We have wellness advisors if people aren't working with their doctor and just wanna talk with people, ask questions. And we encourage people to call in
我们有模块，我们只是教授我们在过去23年中学到的ABC原则。它们并不难，但大学里不教。它们就是不教，至少在我们过去23年学到的程度上。它们并不难，但大学里不教。它们就是不教，至少在我们教授它们的程度上。如果人们不与他们的医生合作，只是想和人交谈，问问题，我们有健康顾问。我们鼓励人们打电话
and find out everyone's a little bit different, okay? And it's amazing what nutrition can do, but it's also amazing what stops nutrition from working, you know. So we talk a little bit about those principles. Yes. There actually are, you know, Corey mentions that these things have not been covered. There's very little nutrition instruction for medical doctors, for example.
并发现每个人都有点不同，好的？营养能做的事情令人惊叹，但阻止营养发挥作用的事情也令人惊叹，你知道。所以我们谈论一点这些原则。是的。实际上有，你知道，Corey提到这些事情没有被涵盖。例如，对医学博士的营养指导很少。
Because it's not patentable. And the person who's teaching them doesn't know it, and they're taught by going into a hospital. And I mean, when I was in outpatient social work and we're a sort of community treatment team, so we got the worst of the worst cases of people in the state that were actively psychotic and going to ERs all the time,
因为它是不可申请专利的。而且教他们的人不知道它，他们是通过进入医院来学习的。我的意思是，当我在门诊社会工作时，我们是一个社区治疗团队，所以我们得到了该州最糟糕的病例，那些积极精神病且一直去急诊室的人，
and we're trying to engage them. Like part of my job at that point was to have medical students in my car for part of their residency to teach or not residency. What there's part of their, when they're students to teach them, that was part of their psych rotation. And they liked it because the psych rotation in the ER is kind of boring, but that was like, so many were like, why don't they teach me this in the hospital? Or I can't wait to get out of the hospital so I can learn the way that other things do it. Cause we, we don't think about how much of their school that it's, we think it's all textbook and tests and they come out and they know everything. I mean, a lot of it is just following another doctor around garbage in garbage out,
我们正在试图让他们参与进来。就像我当时工作的一部分是让医学生在我的车里进行部分住院医师实习，以教导，或者不是住院医师。什么是他们的一部分，当他们是学生时教他们，那是他们精神科轮转的一部分。他们喜欢它，因为急诊室的精神科轮转有点无聊，但那是，很多人说，为什么他们不在医院教我这个？或者我迫不及待地想离开医院，这样我就可以学习其他事情的做法。因为我们，我们不考虑他们的学校有多少，我们认为这全是教科书和考试，他们出来后就知道了一切。我的意思是，很多只是跟随另一个医生，垃圾进垃圾出。
you know, like if the doctor from 1980 wasn't trained well and isn't doing a good job. And then you put a student with them and tell the student to follow them around, what are they learning? You know? And I mean, really all the students that were bright and fun, they understood these systems. We had these conversations while they're in my car and they were like, how do you know this stuff and where did you learn it? And I could give them different resources, but they're medical students, you know, nearing the end of their thing. Talking to a social worker that's been out of school for an hour and, you know, is has enough obsession to read all night long instead of sleeping. Like what what is our system? Right. Yeah.
你知道，如果1980年的医生训练不足，工作做得不好，然后你让一个学生跟着他们，告诉学生去模仿他们，他们能学到什么呢？你知道吗？我的意思是，那些聪明又有趣的学生，他们其实理解这些系统。我们在车里聊天时，他们会问我，你是怎么知道这些东西的，你在哪学的？我可以给他们提供不同的资源，但他们是医学生，你知道，快要毕业了。他们却在和一个刚毕业没多久的社会工作者聊天，而这个社工有足够的执着，整晚都在阅读而不是睡觉。我们的系统到底是怎么回事？对吧。是的。
So it's it's changing there. There are many psychiatrists we've trained over the years, primary care doctors, nurse practitioners, as well as therapists of many kinds. And we're grateful for all of them. They come with a wealth of knowledge, right? And they can apply that knowledge in the case of medications in a critical way. For example, they're not trained to take people off medications, nearly like they're trained to put them on medications. Um, we'll just talk to them. I don't know if they need the medication. We don't even do that anymore. It's like, right. We shifted medicine to billable services, which, and so with psychiatry, the free market is frustrated because it's like, where's the service? You're not doing an operation.
所以情况正在改变。多年来我们培训了许多精神科医生、初级保健医生、执业护士以及各种治疗师。我们感谢他们所有人。他们带来了丰富的知识，对吧？他们可以在药物治疗的情况下以批判性的方式应用这些知识。例如，他们受到的训练并不是如何让人们停药，而是如何让他们开始服药。嗯，我们会和他们谈谈。我不知道他们是否真的需要药物。我们甚至不再那样做了。就像，对吧。我们将医学转变为可计费的服务，所以对于精神病学来说，自由市场感到沮丧，因为它就像，服务在哪里？你又不是在做手术。
So it's, you know, we talk to you for anywhere from five to 15 minutes and then put you on a pill. That is not enough time. You don't know me. You don't know what's going on. You know what I want you to know. You know, you don't know if I'm smart enough to trick you. You don't know if I feel like I'm not allowed to say this stuff because of the household I came from. You don't know if my self-image is lining up with my actual, you don't know any of this stuff. Right. You know, the screener about domestic abuse and do i fall in my house and all the stuff that you your reliability management team made me do i spend more time doing that than i do bliss talking to a doctor and the doctors don't read that stuff the crp is supposed to go through it and see if maybe i'm getting a view they don't you know right if there's anything
所以，你知道，我们和你谈话的时间从5到15分钟不等，然后就给你开药。这时间根本不够。你不了解我。你不知道发生了什么。你知道的是我想让你知道的。你知道，你不知道我是否聪明到可以骗你。你不知道我是否因为我出身的家庭环境而觉得我不被允许说这些话。你不知道我的自我形象是否与我的实际情况相符，你根本不知道这些。对吧。你知道，关于家庭虐待和我在家里是否跌倒的筛查，以及你那所谓的可靠性管理团队让我做的所有事情，我花在这些上面的时间比我真正和医生交谈的时间还要多，而且医生根本不看那些东西。CRP应该检查一下，看看我是否可能受到虐待，但他们没有，你知道，对吧，如果有什么
that's appropriate in in with that approach from our perspective it's nutrients because everyone needs these essential nutrients and you can talk with a person for 10 or 15 minutes and say i wonder if you're needing some more essential nutrients let's try that it won't hurt you know uh in the case of using them together with medications it needs to be carefully monitored because there are medication effects that can increase over medication. Are there any contraindications? Like I'm not a medical doctor, so nothing I'm saying is medical advice. You guys have different training, but you're not acting as SMDs on here, you know, but like if I'm on, you know, blood
从我们的角度来看，这种方法是合适的，那就是营养素，因为每个人都需要这些必需营养素。你可以和一个人谈10到15分钟，然后说，我想知道你是否需要更多必需营养素，让我们试试看，这不会有坏处。你知道，嗯，在将它们与药物一起使用的情况下，需要仔细监测，因为药物作用可能会增加，导致药物过量。有什么禁忌症吗？我不是医生，所以我说的都不是医疗建议。你们有不同的培训，但你们在这里不是以医学博士的身份行事，你知道，但如果我正在服用，你知道，血液
thinners, whatever, can I just go grab a hearty product? Do I need to know anything about doctor indications? You do. And we recommend that people work, if they're taking any prescription medication, that they work with a prescribing clinician in the process. And we have a map we've created. We've worked with, trained many prescribing clinicians and those who are accepting patients may choose to list their practice on our website and we have a find a locator i find a health professional locator and it it includes therapists of many kinds and nurse practitioners medical doctors psychiatrists and you, you know, a person
稀释剂之类的，我可以随便买个Hardy的产品吗？我需要了解任何关于医生禁忌症的信息吗？你需要。我们建议人们，如果他们正在服用任何处方药，他们应该在过程中与开处方的临床医生合作。我们创建了一张地图。我们已经与许多开处方的临床医生合作并进行了培训，那些正在接收病人的医生可以选择将他们的诊所列在我们的网站上，我们有一个寻找健康专业人士的定位器，它包括各种治疗师、执业护士、医学博士、精神科医生，而且你，你知道，一个人
can search for what they're looking for in a practitioner. But, you know, they need to go through individually with a practitioner to assess their needs. It really is. It's more than just throw the essential nutrients at people. And we get a clear, consistent response with everybody. With many people, especially when they're unmedicated, if they try it first, before they use medications, it's a much simpler road. And many people are very pleased with the results. Sometimes it requires some extra expertise. You mentioned L-theanine and acetylcysteine might be useful and other things. Well, a lot of people, they want the product that has the ECCG in it, but the pure green tea extract has a lot of caffeine.
可以搜索他们正在寻找的从业者。但是，你知道，他们需要与从业者单独沟通以评估他们的需求。这确实不仅仅是把必需营养素扔给人们那么简单。我们从每个人那里都得到了清晰、一致的反应。对于许多人，特别是当他们没有服药时，如果他们在服药前先尝试这个，这是一个简单得多的道路。许多人对结果非常满意。有时它需要一些额外的专业知识。你提到了茶氨酸和乙酰半胱氨酸可能有用，还有其他东西。嗯，很多人想要含有EGCG的产品，但纯绿茶提取物含有大量的咖啡因。
And the best way to come off of Adderall is not to just take a ton of caffeine. Now, L-theanine is able to stimulate focus without being a stimulant. Excellent. Yeah. And we, you know, this is a good point. Even substances like caffeine, marijuana, nicotine, we've seen significant interactions with. And so an individual doing this on their own can get interference effects from these things. So the good news here is people who are drinking multiple cups of coffee or tea a day for the caffeine effect to keep themselves energized find over time they don't need to use as much. That's what we've
而戒掉阿得拉（Adderall）的最好方法不是摄入大量的咖啡因。现在，茶氨酸能够在不成为兴奋剂的情况下刺激专注力。太棒了。是的，我们，你知道，这是一个很好的观点。即使是咖啡因、大麻、尼古丁等物质，我们也观察到了显著的相互作用。因此，个人独自这样做可能会从这些东西中获得干扰效应。所以这里的好消息是，那些每天喝几杯咖啡或茶以获取咖啡因效果来保持精力充沛的人，随着时间的推移发现他们不需要使用那么多了。这就是我们
observed. We actually have a blinded trial, a randomized double-blind placebo-controlled trial with cigarette cessation using daily essential nutrients. This was done in New Zealand. They found the most robust effect of the trial was they smoked less over time. And the initial observation was not just cigarettes, but marijuana as well. People would spontaneously just lower the amount they were using. But you're just falling asleep naturally. You know, I reach for whatever you're reaching for. Yeah. falling asleep naturally you know I reach for your whatever you're reaching for yeah so the good news is people tend not to feel the need as much or these substances over time as they use nutrients you have any evidence from any of the studies you've done that it changes the gammaBA. Interesting. Well, that's interesting.
观察到的。我们实际上有一个盲法试验，一项使用每日必需营养素进行戒烟的随机双盲安慰剂对照试验。这是在新西兰完成的。他们发现试验中最强劲的效果是随着时间的推移，他们抽烟变少了。最初的观察不仅是香烟，还有大麻。人们会自发地减少他们使用的量。但你只是自然地入睡了。你知道，我伸手去拿你正在拿的任何东西。是的，自然地入睡，你知道，我伸手去拿你正在拿的任何东西，是的，所以好消息是，随着时间的推移，当人们使用营养素时，他们往往不会那么强烈地感觉到对这些物质的需求。你从你所做的任何研究中有任何证据表明它改变了GABA吗？有趣。嗯，这很有趣。
We don't have that specifically. That would be my guess. That's probably why it changes the effect of the medication as well, or it changes the effect of marijuana use or something as well. Yes. We see plenty of evidence that it would be effective if we were to study that specifically. And we're not like a pharmaceutical company with millions of dollars, billions of dollars to pour into this research. And we're not really interested in doing that. We want an independent investigation. Well, yeah, I mean, that's like we're so obsessed with like the, um, the quality of the study internally,
我们没有具体的证据。那可能是我的猜测。这可能就是为什么它也会改变药物的效果，或者它也会改变大麻使用的效果之类的原因。是的。我们看到了大量的证据表明，如果我们专门研究这一点，它将是有效的。而且我们不像制药公司那样有数百万、数十亿美元投入到这项研究中。我们真的没有兴趣那样做。我们想要独立的调查。嗯，是的，我的意思是，我们太痴迷于研究的内部质量了，
but we don't look at the external system, which is real frustrating to me. I mean, it's like, yeah, they were incredibly, um, the research design was flawless and what, um, uh, these cigarette companies use for 20 years to prove that we really just can't figure out if there's any link between cigarettes and cancer. I mean, that research was so high quality. Some of the best PhDs in the world are on that stuff. Sure. Right. The good news here is we have medications that we're replacing with nutrients, GABAergic medications. And so we have strong evidence from our perspective.
但我们没有审视外部系统，这让我感到非常沮丧。我的意思是，是的，它们非常，嗯，研究设计是完美的，而且，嗯，这些香烟公司用了20年时间来证明我们真的无法确定香烟和癌症之间是否有任何联系。我的意思是，那项研究的质量非常高。世界上一些最好的博士都在研究这些东西。当然。对吧。这里的好消息是，我们有正在用营养素替代的药物，即GABA能药物。所以从我们的角度来看，我们有强有力的证据。
If you're to consult with psychiatrists who have used this for many years, they would say there's strong evidence that we're affecting GABA. What do nutrients not affect in the body? That's the real question. It's nothing. Everything is affected by nutrients. And that's a huge difference between a magic bullet approach of a medication, even a few different medications used together. There are very limited mechanisms of action involved. With nutrients, there are a multitude of mechanisms known and many really sparsely known. Vitamin K has receptors in the brain. You mentioned a blood clotting
如果你去咨询那些使用这种方法多年的精神科医生，他们会说有强有力的证据表明我们正在影响GABA。营养素对身体有什么没有影响吗？这才是真正的问题。什么都没有。一切都受到营养素的影响。这就是药物的“灵丹妙药”方法与即使是几种不同药物一起使用之间的巨大区别。涉及的作用机制非常有限。对于营养素，有多种已知的机制，还有许多鲜为人知的机制。维生素K在大脑中有受体。你提到了血液凝固
medication. That's an interaction that could happen with blood clotting medications. Vitamin K could be involved. We have vitamin K in our product, so it's not a good idea just to add the nutrients. Curcumin is another one you don't really want to take with the blood. Right. So these things need to be carefully monitored. Noxacil can also make your medication anywhere from 40 to 12 times more effective if that's one that it slows down the liver processing of, which is not people getting trouble. Yes, that is a major interaction. So Corey went through the pharmacodynamic interaction where the nutrients are used in the body. We're building the base of nutrients and more serotonin is produced and it's regulated better. More dopamine is produced, it's regulated better.
药物。那是一种可能与血液凝固药物发生的相互作用。维生素K可能参与其中。我们的产品中有维生素K，所以仅仅添加营养素并不是一个好主意。姜黄素是另一种你真的不想和血液药物一起服用的东西。对吧。所以这些事情需要仔细监测。Noxacil也可以使你的药物效果提高40到12倍，如果它是减慢肝脏处理速度的那种药物，这并不是人们遇到麻烦的原因。是的，这是一个主要的相互作用。所以Corey经历了药效学相互作用，即营养素在体内是如何被使用的。我们正在建立营养素的基础，产生更多的血清素，并且调节得更好。产生更多的多巴胺，调节得更好。
And all of those functions require nutrients. In addition to that, the liver enzymes and intestinal enzymes, cytochrome P450 enzymes, are a major source of interactions with medications. We speak with medical doctors all the time. This catches their attention. They know they need to monitor medication levels when they learn, and many of them have not. They don't have it on their radar, at least, that the synergy effect of these nutrients used together is known to affect medications. Even taking nutrients separately, considering them separately, vitamin D inhibits nine different cytochrome P450 enzymes that we've found in the literature. And it includes all of the major ones, CYP3A4, CYP2D6. is listed as a moderate or a major interaction effect with different medications involving
所有这些功能都需要营养素。除此之外，肝酶和肠道酶，即细胞色素P450酶，是与药物相互作用的主要来源。我们一直与医生交谈。这引起了他们的注意。他们知道当他们学习时需要监测药物水平，而许多人并没有这样做。他们至少没有意识到，这些营养素一起使用的协同效应已知会影响药物。即使是单独服用营养素，单独考虑它们，维生素D也会抑制我们在文献中发现的九种不同的细胞色素P450酶。它包括所有主要的酶，CYP3A4，CYP2D6。被列为与涉及以下方面的不同药物的中度或重度相互作用效应
cytochrome p450-384 that's the most common one used to process medications in the body and 2d6 these enzymes are actually naturally used for vitamin d itself that Some of them are called vitamin D3 hydroxylase. That's the name of the enzyme. It's used for vitamin D in the body, but the medications come along and the body uses the same enzyme. So it's a competitive effect. The body can't clear the medication as quickly because vitamin D is there. Now you think of the implications here seasonally. Many people in the United States have vitamin D produced in the skin if they're outside. Many people are not, but if they're outside, they can have a lot more vitamin D in the summertime than in the wintertime. They might be over-medicated in the summertime because the vitamin D is blocking the excretion of medication's metabolism.
细胞色素P450-3A4，这是体内处理药物最常用的酶，还有2D6。这些酶实际上是维生素D本身自然使用的。其中一些被称为维生素D3羟化酶。这就是酶的名字。它在体内用于维生素D，但药物随之而来，身体使用相同的酶。所以这是一种竞争效应。身体不能像以前那样快速清除药物，因为维生素D在那里。现在你考虑一下季节性的影响。在美国，许多人如果待在户外，皮肤会产生维生素D。许多人没有，但如果他们在户外，夏天比冬天会有更多的维生素D。他们可能在夏天服药过量，因为维生素D阻碍了药物代谢的排泄。
So the medication builds up in their bloodstream. People say eventually, after a few days out in the sun, they say, I don't feel well in the sun. They think there's something with the sun. Well, I think this might be a mechanism involved. Vitamin D is increasing, and it's increasing the side effects of medications. As a result, more medication is being kept in the body. It's not able to be processed and excreted. And so in the wintertime, the opposite could happen.
所以药物在他们的血液中积聚。人们说最终，在阳光下待了几天后，他们说，我在阳光下感觉不舒服。他们认为这与太阳有关。嗯，我认为这可能涉及一种机制。维生素D正在增加，它正在增加药物的副作用。结果，更多的药物被保留在体内。它无法被处理和排泄。所以到了冬天，相反的情况可能会发生。
Right? Vitamin D levels are low. A person might be lacking medication. They might feel more depressed on their antidepressant in the wintertime when they're not producing as much vitamin D. So you have these fluctuations. I think those are very real. And a person can smooth those out by supplementing with vitamin D and keeping a more constant level throughout the year. But the good news is they could also achieve the ideal in our experience.
对吧？维生素D水平很低。一个人可能会缺乏药物。当他们在冬天没有产生那么多维生素D时，他们可能会在服用抗抑郁药时感到更加抑郁。所以你有这些波动。我认为这些是非常真实的。一个人可以通过补充维生素D并在全年保持更恒定的水平来平滑这些波动。但好消息是，根据我们的经验，他们也可以达到理想状态。
Well, in a lot of natural conditions, I'm sorry, go ahead. There's kind of a... Gradually lowering the medication over time with the help of a prescribing clinician, right? And eventually what we find is the optimal dose of medication is zero. Yeah.
嗯，在许多自然条件下，抱歉，请继续。有一种……在处方临床医生的帮助下逐渐降低药物剂量，对吧？最终我们发现药物的最佳剂量是零。是的。
Well, and there's a million examples, but if you go through kind of older, you know, ancient world traditions, a ton of this stuff was just naturally figuring out how to manage these things. A lot of food culture is around that, you know, um, it was relatively modern, you know, that they started to make sauerkraut so that people didn't get scurvy on boats because you could keep sauerkraut, but you couldn't really keep citrus fruits. Right. I mean, even going back like the ancient Vikings, I mean, you drink mead in the wintertime. Um, and the mead there is different than what we're making now. When you use honey must, and a lot of the natural stuff, you end up with vitamin K and vitamin D and probiotics that you're not getting as much sun you know in the in the winter because it's cold and to survive in norway you got to be in the meat hauler you know the pit with the fire um whereas in the summer you're out on the on the ocean so you know a ton of those
嗯，有无数的例子，但如果你回顾古代世界的传统，很多东西都是自然地弄清楚如何管理这些事情的。很多饮食文化都是围绕着这个，你知道，嗯，这是相对现代的，你知道，他们开始制作酸菜，这样人们在船上就不会得坏血病，因为你可以保存酸菜，但你不能真正保存柑橘类水果。对吧。我的意思是，即使追溯到古代维京人，我的意思是，你在冬天喝蜂蜜酒。嗯，那里的蜂蜜酒和我们现在制作的不同。当你使用蜂蜜浆和许多天然的东西时，你最终会得到维生素K、维生素D和益生菌，因为你在冬天没有得到那么多阳光，你知道，因为天气很冷，为了在挪威生存，你必须待在蜂蜜酒窖里，你知道，那个有火的坑，而在夏天你是在海洋上，所以你知道，很多
things are just the society left alone you, naturally figures out how to kind of regulate itself. And it comes up with ways to make these things tradition, even if we don't know why. But a lot of how we sort of are failing to have a myth or guiding principle or any sort of, you know, cultural center in the modern world. We lose all that stuff. And then we don't know why we feel bad. And you guys are part of the project of trying to rebuild those things and and money makes it difficult okay yeah i mean that's the problem yeah if you look you talk about citrus and scurvy on the boats a lot of people have heard about that how long do you think it took them to mandate that over a
事情只是社会让你独自一人，自然地弄清楚如何自我调节。它想出了将这些东西变成传统的方法，即使我们不知道为什么。但我们在现代世界中在某种程度上未能拥有神话、指导原则或任何形式的文化中心，这在很大程度上是我们的失败。我们失去了所有这些东西。然后我们不知道为什么我们感觉不好。你们是试图重建这些东西的项目的一部分，而金钱使这变得困难。好吧，是的，我的意思是，这就是问题所在。是的，如果你看看，你谈论船上的柑橘和坏血病，很多人都听说过，你认为他们强制执行这个花了多长时间？
hundred years since they first found it out so sometimes things are a little bit slow and but there we talk a lot about science stuff here but there's so much stuff beyond the you know the metabolism and all the vitamins and the lithium whatever it is you got the mom that's sick and tired of going to the principal's office because her kids can't can't be handled in school right and then the mom decides to try this and a month or two later you know some things really start changing and the kid doesn't visit the principal's office anymore you know and we've been doing this for 23 years we got just about 40 medical journal publications 40 of them and the evidence is pretty clear, at least to me, that if you give your body what it needs, that it will repair itself. Nutrition isn't the fast train, but it's the right track to be on.
一百年，从他们第一次发现它开始。所以有时事情有点慢，但我们在谈论很多科学的东西，但除了你知道的新陈代谢和所有的维生素、锂之类的东西之外，还有很多东西。你有那个厌倦了去校长办公室的妈妈，因为她的孩子在学校里无法被管教，对吧？然后妈妈决定尝试这个，一两个月后，你知道，一些事情真的开始改变了，孩子不再去校长办公室了。你知道，我们已经这样做23年了，我们有大约40篇医学期刊出版物，40篇，证据非常清楚，至少对我来说，如果你给你的身体它所需要的，它就会自我修复。营养不是快车，但它是正确的轨道。
And we would suggest that give it a try first. If something needs to happen, either medications or you need to change some things, give nutrition a try first and see if it'll help. There are circumstances where people do still need a little bit of medications to keep them stable. Okay. Not anti-pharma, but we understand a little bit what's happening in the body. And we really thank you for your time today to kind of get into these nuts and bolts of things, Joel. It's been really good. Yeah, we really appreciate you guys' time.
我们建议先试一试。如果需要发生什么，无论是药物还是你需要改变一些事情，先尝试营养，看看它是否有帮助。在某些情况下，人们确实仍然需要一点药物来保持稳定。好的。不是反制药，但我们稍微了解身体里发生了什么。我们非常感谢你今天抽出时间来深入了解这些基本的东西，Joel。这真的很好。是的，我们非常感谢你们的时间。
Thank you for having me. And we'll definitely put anything that you'd like in the show notes. We'll link to your website, which is hardy.com. What is it? HardyNutritionals.com. HardyNutritionals.com or gethardy.com. Okay. We'll link to that and um you know if anyone has any questions i'll just let them you know reach out to you guys um it's
谢谢你们邀请我。我们肯定会把任何你想要的东西放在节目说明中。我们会链接到你的网站，即hardy.com。是什么？HardyNutritionals.com。HardyNutritionals.com或gethardy.com。好的。我们会链接到那个，嗯，你知道，如果任何人有任何问题，我会让他们，你知道，联系你们，嗯，这是
it's not a product that you can get through taproot right now so you know um you know reach out if you have a question thank you so much for your time guys working out sleeping in taking vitamins vitamin a vitamin b vitamin c vitamin d vitamin bitch vitamin please There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这不是你现在可以通过Taproot获得的产品，所以你知道，嗯，你知道，如果你有疑问请联系我们。非常感谢你们的时间。锻炼、睡觉、服用维生素、维生素A、维生素B、维生素C、维生素D、维生素Bitch、维生素Please。这个剧集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。